e
to
good morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs we have
several bills scheduled for public
hearing today but before we get to those
I would ask you to please join me in the
Allegiance pledge allegiance to the flag
of the United States of America and to
the Republic
is
Nation
thank you
everyone the first bill for our
consideration today is HB 559 and I will
recognize the prime sponsor
representative roads from chesher
17 and representative roads we do need a
pink card from you too but but after
your testimony is
good morning Mr chairman Madame Vice
chairman members of the committee for
the record my name is representative
Jennifer rhs I represent Chester County
District 17 which is Winchester Richmond
Swansea Troy and Fitz
William the bill I bring in front of you
this after or this morning um I would
ask that you would give me a little bit
of a professional courtesy here this is
not my wheelhouse and I wrote this for a
constituent I I talked with many people
and I know it's a little bit
controversial
um and when I agreed to bring this bill
forward I was very very clear with my
constituent that I'm in the criminal
justice committee and I know absolutely
nothing about medical care of any sort I
don't even do lose teeth and when I let
him know that I would expect him to show
up and testify with me and help me you
know with the the questioning of the
bill and exactly how this is going to to
be implemented I was given his word that
here he knows it's 9:30 a.m. not 9:30
p.m. right right so when I let him know
that you know we were up on Wednesday
morning I got the text back that said oh
my gosh I'm so sorry I have a feeling I
might be too um that his work schedule
has changed and unfortunately he will
not be able to come help me with the
bill so with that being said I I'm
fortunate enough to have uh our
colleague representative PR as a
co-sponsor who is a professional
paramedic and he has helped me with the
bill and he is also not able to be here
um just yet but he is coming so I would
ask when he does arrive um if you do
need to recess if you're finished when
he arrives if you could uh kindly maybe
reopen the hearing to let him really dig
in on on how this bill would be
implemented I would just ask that sure
okay
so the fire chief in my town came to me
and this was a this was a situation that
he's brought to my attention many many
times and he kept on telling me how
during covid there were was basically an
emergency order that allowed a paramedic
to still go to a home and have one
person be the medical provider and one
person be the dver driver my
understanding is as it as a law is that
both people in the the rig if you will
have to be certified EMT so during covid
um they had this emergency order and it
was just a little bit easier for people
to be able to get the calls you're
allowed to have one person Drive you're
allowed to have one person care for the
patient and then that went away the
problem is the Staffing is still an
issue that that issue has not gone away
but the emergency order that was
allowing departments to be able to go
and still give care if needed that went
away so what I did is I I reached out to
several people that I know that are in
the house that you know are firefighters
and EMTs a couple of them one of them
um is works over in a larger City and he
said to me roads that never happened
that never that never took place there's
always two sets of eyes on the patient
always always always said well I I
respectfully disagree because I've
talked to maybe 15 people and they're
all telling me that they absolutely took
advantage of that emergency order and it
was very very helpful so what that tells
me is in the big city or larger City if
you will that's not a problem and that's
great for you but this is addressing the
smaller towns that have volunteer
people that are working they don't have
the Staffing requirements a lot of them
work full-time jobs some of them are
only allow are able to volunteer in the
morning afternoon evening whatever have
you if if the situation was allowed to
be permanent what was during covid that
would take a tremendous strain off of
some of these small towns and still
allow them to be able to give the care
that they were able to give during covid
so um some of the questions and the
concerns I had was well things can turn
very quickly and go from an okay
situation to a bad situation well I I
would certainly agree with that that is
where my colleague representative PR
would be better to answer this my
understanding is calls come in and their
a I believe it's like a through e as far
as the you know the level of of the call
obviously if you get a call that is on
more of an very very emergent side this
is not going to be able to this is not
going to be able to happen you're going
to need more people however if
it's a call that I've you know had to
make with kidney stone that I can assure
you that there was only ever one person
that was helping me and one person that
was driving so after the bill was
written it was kind of brought up
that maybe maybe everybody in the
vehicle doesn't have to be certified but
perhaps the person that's driving is at
least is at least a member of either the
fire department or you know part part of
that that department if you will so with
all that being said there's my
man um with all that being said what I
would ask is when when somebody comes
into criminal justice and they say to us
well this is your wheelhouse and you
know you guys do whatever you want to do
I that that's kind of irksome and I'm
not going to do that to you I'm not
going to say hey this is your bill do
whatever you want to do what I would ask
is if you do think that there's Merit
here but it's just not workable exactly
as it is give me the opportunity to fix
it I'm not asking you to do the work for
me I'm just asking you to give me the
opportunity to do what would need to be
done to make this be able to be a
passable Bill and with that I would ask
that my uh my colleague representative
kru can explain the differences between
levels of emergency
calls I thought good morning
representative Po and I'll also need a
pink card from you after you get
situated in after your testimony
please luckily for
me anyway so representative Mark PR uh
Hillsboro 15 which is Manchester w 8
uh I'm a firefighter EMT deputy chief in
the town of eping worked in the city of
Nashville for 30 years retired as
Lieutenant would do you need me to tell
them I thank you I would I would I would
like you to explain the difference
levels of calls so where this would
actually be able to be helpful so
I'll start my little story is that
getting people to come into the fire and
EMS service right
now is worse than pulling teeth nobody
wants to come to these jobs so from time
to time we find ourselves very short
especially of uh EMT or higher
levels uh and we were able to use during
covid a firefighter as a driver of our
ambulance
which helped us
greatly and when that
stopped we have trouble Manning uh two
people two EMS people in the truck from
time to time doesn't happen all the time
uh sometimes we have two calls back to
back because we try to have at least one
full
crew uh and we can usually have a a
third
one but that fourth person is tough if
you're pushing out a second ambulance
it's tough to get two EMS people but we
may have a firefighter that can drive
for us and that's all that we're looking
for is that ability it's not the
something that we're going to strive to
use we don't want to put one EMS and one
firefighter
driver unless it's absolutely
necessary but we want that option so we
can continue that care we can get that
person to the hospital in timely fashion
so they can get that higher level of
care right and uh the level of calls go
from oh I stub my toe in the
dark to Cardiac
Arrest right usually with Cardiac Arrest
we have ALS coming um which is an
intercept truck in my area a lot of
people don't have that extra piece right
so if I have two EMS people I want both
of them in the back and maybe that
firefighter can drive the two EMTs to
the hospital while they're working the
code so we're just looking for some
flexibility to be able to to keep things
moving
forward um because if we don't get that
person we are now calling a mutual Aid
ambulance hopefully they're not tied up
because I'm going to tell you
they' been in the fire service for a
very long time we used to have a lot of
fires we don't have a lot of fires we
have a lot of medical calls more and
more and more as this population gets
older uh sometimes they seem to be
getting
sicker and I don't like to call it abuse
but we get called a lot of times when
somebody probably could have drove thems
to the hospital hospital or had somebody
driving themselves so that's tying up
that primary ambulance and and I'm
usually the third guy as the deputy
chief and I just sit there and Shake
because I know the really bad Call's
coming it always happens as a second
call not always but so if we can get out
the door with two people we can keep
moving right we can load that patient we
can get him in the ambulance start
treatment and if we're lucky alss can
meet us and I get an extra set of hands
in the back um but if not we're at least
moving the patient to the hospital in a
timely
fashion and with that I'll take
questions if you have them right any
representative
Weber thank you very much and thank you
for taking my question um my questions
have to do with the choices in the
Bill's drafting because I don't know
about the underlying ruem but I notice
that the choice was made to put this in
the rulle making section of the statute
so what it's doing is putting a limit on
the rule making authority of the
department so that um they can't require
more than one emergency person and so I
was wondering if you guys could direct
me to or perhaps email me links to the
underlying rules so we could take a look
at that
and uh
secondarily would you want to specify
because it doesn't specify here and I
don't know what's in the rules that the
driver must at a minimum be have
firefighter training rather than uh just
whoever they pulled in off the street
that morning so I can assure you if they
don't belong to a department they're not
driving an ambulance they're not driving
anything okay so insurance and stuff
like that takes care of all that oh yeah
and and our rules our guidelines our
Sops if you're not a member of the
department or a department that we know
you don't get behind the wheel of my
truck okay thank you that's a
reassurance Mr chairman if I may just
add sure something to representative
Weber thank you for the question when I
when this was drafted as I mentioned
when I was you know trying to introduce
the
bill when when the fire chief kept
explaining this to me I was able to find
out through all the questions I was
saying that I was asking that it indeed
was a rule that was temporarily
suspended and that is why I am trying to
change that rule to make that permanent
so that's one thing um
additionally that's um also when I had
mentioned that after that it was drafted
is when the terminology about somebody
that's at least within the department be
the driver and I would very I would
happily add that in here to to make that
be permanent but that's where I was
asking about giving me the opportunity
to change that if it's even something
that you're willing to have a discussion
about that that wouldn't be a problem
having the assurance that and I I'm sure
that the practice is probably Universal
because of all of those things that I
hadn't thought of when I asked the
question but thank you thank you
representative
lontine thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question and maybe I'm not
really understanding this well but it
seems to me
that your this language is saying um you
must have only one person not more than
that when it seems like you're as what
you really want is to say the rules you
may only have one person in the back
like it it seems like it's really
limiting uh it to say only one person
you I not no I don't I don't I can
assure you if we need more than one
person we're putting more than one
person in the back well it says provided
that not more than one emergency medical
care provider shall be required so
that's should be required right so we
can run with only one medical person and
that firefighter driver yeah that's what
that's telling
me that you only need one medical person
the other person can be that and it's
going to be the firefighter driver okay
um can I just have one other follow up
yeah
and um this may be not quite relevant
but you brought up the calls where you
feel like many of them are
unnecessary and and maybe
unnecessary um in my
observations with ambulances I often see
a a call that over something um that
does not seem critically urgent like
someone spraining their ankle while
they're running or um and then but the
fire Tru is shows up
automatically um which seems like a
waste of resources and is there a way
that that can be addressed in rule
making so they come from
Manpower because we trying to avoid
injuries that person on the ground might
be 300 plus pounds so two people trying
to lift that especially if they're in an
awkward position or something uh we want
the manpower to do it safely not only
for us but for the patient right so like
in my in my town we use what we call the
utility it's the pickup truck so the
third person comes in the pickup truck
so that way because if we put all three
people in the in the ambulance at that
time if there's a second call all three
people are at the hospital so uh one
person's out and we like during the day
for my department our administrative
assistant is a EMT as well so she'll
jump in the ambulance with me and we can
go but on that call I'm there to assist
with lifting and if we need more we'll
obviously call more help but that's and
if it's a a serious medical cuz I'm
going to tell
you what you get dispatched as what the
call supposed to be
I'm going to tell you 70% of the time
it's either worse or less right it's
never what it is because you're talking
to civilians who are kind of panicked
and and they're like oh my God there's
blood everywhere and you get there and
there's a little cut and maybe a little
bit of blood but to them right that's a
lot of blood because they don't see
blood often so and like when I say
unnecessary yeah they could have gone by
ambulance uh um by car but to them it's
it's a big deal I I I understand that
and so we take them no matter
what presentive
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
sir for taking my question so um in in
terms of assessing risk and just before
you got here representative Road said
sometimes situations can get out of hand
and so I think that's kind of why the
original rules were there but you you
mentioned that in a situation where
there isn't a vehicle available because
of Staffing or whatever you have to fall
back onto what you called a mutual Aid
vehicle so I was just wondering if you
could for the committee kind of go
through what is that difference between
you know the the emergency service
vehicle the mutual Aid vehicle and what
is the relative risk in both those
situations
so the mutual Aid vehicle is coming from
another town oh right
so all our resources are tied up we
reach out started out in the fire
service right because some fires get so
big that you can't control it with what
you have so we have a mutual Aid System
right
and it's designed that if we need
something we'll go to the next town if
that Town's out we're going to reach to
the next one out right so that's a
longer time for that ambulance to
come right if it's one the town next it
may not be too long but if we're
reaching Two Towns
away you could be 15 plus
minutes and when
you and if we had that extra person in
15 minutes I can be to the
hospital right
so somebody and cardiac arrest 15
minutes on the ground that's a long time
right if they're severe internal
bleeding we can't fix that in the street
that's a operating room all day long so
my goal is to get them there as quick as
we can to that higher level of care
because that gives you the best
results thank you representative Weber
you had your hand up earlier or I'll
representative
damus thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question um just out of
curiosity the verbage that was used in
the uh rules during covid is the
verbiage that you've reintroduced or to
reinstate that rule is that the same
verbiage thank you for taking the
question my I'm sorry thank you for your
question yes I I was given the exact
verbage for the emergency order during
covid and I copied and pasted it right
to
here follow
up thank you so in other words it was it
worked well and it was
adequate if if I may address that uh my
understanding is yes and one of the
things I was going to say whenever
representative PR came in is
that during the conversations I was
having with various professionals that
do this one of the things that I heard
was you we can't do that people are
going to die people are going to die you
have to have two sets of eyes on the
patient all times okay um I heard that
from somebody in my county that told me
that and I said well now we have a
problem don't we because one when a
person's driving their eyes aren't on a
patient they're driving so that that's
not going to fly um
however something's wrong because if
this was okay during Co
and it's not okay now does that mean
that people's lives are worth more or
less during Co or they're worth more or
less now I mean at the end of the day
this this worked during covid and there
are departments that would benefit
greatly to still be able to have this so
I maybe it maybe it was okay then just
because it was an emergency I don't know
but some towns are still in that
emergency
situation representative Lucas I
actually have two questions if I could
um so uh in a situation where you would
have uh a person in the back attending
the patient and a driver if things
really went South you would pull over
basically and the driver would go around
to the back if uh the patient required
resuscitation all of a sudden in the
middle of the transport correct so the
driver would need to be at least CPR
trained most firefighters are at least
first aid in C
right and then my other question is um
since the goal here is flexibility would
it be better to take the language of
limitation out and Define the
flexibility of the Staffing that's
question thank you for your question I
my answer to that would be when I asked
to please give me the opportunity to
work with the committee and I I will do
the work if if that's what it's going to
be then if you could I I would do that
if that's what needed I don't I don't
know how this language needs to look
exactly that's why I copied exactly what
the emergency order was but I I would do
what you would need to do if this was
going to be able to be passed I would
say that it's this will work because it
worked during covid it gave us that
flexibility of putting a firefighter in
the front seat driving um again like I
said most of our firefighters are
CPR um first aid trained minimum of CPR
thank you both yep representative McKay
and then representative
Weber thank you Mr
chairman U if I recall correctly I have
have been very impressed with your work
with
traumatized uh providers and I think
people don't know about that and it's
extremely important but the confusion I
have uh I've had several trips in an
ambulance
uh and everyone was different from the
one before but conquer does a great job
the what concerns me is that if a
emergency medical care provider is not
available will the ambulance not go that
is correct if there's no certified EMS
person the ambulance does not go okay
thank you
representative
Weber so I'm just trying to clarify and
with with an eye to the language uh
right now under the rule that we don't
have in front of us am I correct in
thinking that you don't roll unless you
have two
certified EMS is that right understand
yes and no okay
so if I'm the third person nobody else
and second call comes in I'm going to
take the ambulance to the scene uhhuh
but I'm calling a mutual Aid ambulance
at the same time okay got it because I'm
bringing my toolbox with me gotcha right
so I have all my tools I have my monitor
whatever I need so when I get there I
can I can start treatment and the mutual
Aid will then transport so so now I have
several more follow-ups so so what you
just said says to me that you can go you
can get there you can treat but until
you have a second person you can't put
them in the ambulance and take them
anywhere is that correct okay so that's
that's item number one um item number
two is if we were to pass this language
exactly as it is and as it was under
covid my understanding would be that um
um it
says not more than one shall be
required
so the ru making the board with
rulemaking authority actually has the
authority to say you don't even have to
have one but they're unlikely to do that
because they're a professional board and
Common Sense dictates even to those of
us who are not trained that you would
have to have at least one but they are
forbidden to require
to is that what this is saying to you
yeah correct that's just saying it in in
in positive language rather than
negative language so we could write it
that only a minimum of one EMS
professional is required right and I I'm
I'm not looking to actually mess with
this it's just little to confusing use
their language that was in place for
covid because we all understood how that
worked and it worked really well so we
figured why I fix it if it's not broken
but if you want it changed we are happy
to do that okay yep thank you very much
that's helpful to me okay representative
woods and then representative kessle
ring well thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question um sometimes
uh these rules are uh used in places
that are unintended and so um maybe
being a little bit nitpicky um
vehicles um does that include
helicopters um U um watercraft that are
ambulances as well um Regular transport
planes helicopter versus a plane do that
would that then apply as a vehicle or in
this setting is it meant that this is
basically you know rubber on the road
type of vehicle so I'm going to tell you
probably rubber on the road because I
know aeromedical has their own set of
rules that are separate from ground
ambulance
so there yeah there's no risk of overlap
that someone running a want wanting to
come into New Hampshire run a helicopter
Service uh say well I only can do ah now
I can only I'm only required to have one
this says driver not pil it yeah so so
I'm going to tell they have their own
set of rules that are totally different
from ground ambulance okay right that
that's a whole and I I don't know what
they are but I know they're pretty
stringent and uh it's usually a medic
and a flight nurse or PA one um under u
a medical care provider um is there a is
that a definition with licensing yes is
that u i mean so there's a there's a
definition someplace in RSA yep that
tells me exactly what that is yep so
there's uh different levels of medical
care provider but under medical care
provider you're either
uh EMR EMT Advanced EMT or paramedic and
those are outlined in RSA thank you yes
representative kessle ring thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
so looking at this it does specify a lot
of things about the vehicle specifically
so my question for you is is there a
specific training that has to be done
inorder to be able to drive that vehicle
that would have to be changed or is that
the same okay same right because they're
usually driving a big bigger vehicle
that's a lot heavier and and is kind of
wildly to handle so an ambulance is much
easier okay follow up follow up the only
reason I ask is because of how the
statute outlines the different
maintenance communication medical
equipment safety you know there's a lot
of detail to that so there's no
difference in the training for that
vehicle versus a fir truck nope okay the
driving piece is the same thank you any
other
questions okay seeing done thank you
thank you Mr thank you again if you
could give us those pink cars that' be
you also signed up to speak is Claudius
Commissioner no that's fine I I
need um good morning and thank you for
giving me the opportunity to speak with
you my my name is Claudia Stewart I am a
chesher county commissioner a former
EMT and the primary caregiver for my
mother-in-law while she was dying from
heart failure I'm here to speak in
opposition of House Bill
559 I don't know if any of you have been
in the back of an ambulance either for
yourself or a loved one I have and in
that moment of Crisis you want the
highest quality of
care a modern-day ambulance is basically
a rolling ER the qualified trained staff
perform life-saving tasks and provide
critical prehospital care and I'm going
to say again prehosp care an ambulance
is more than a
taxi it's not just about getting
somebody to the hospital quickly but
doing what is necessary to keep them
alive while you're transporting
them if during a transport additional
help is needed and the driver is also an
EMT they can pull over get in the back
and assist with life-saving
care I understand that some Fire EMS
departments are struggling with trying
to hire trained EMT and might opt to put
a driver with no medical training in an
ambulance with an
EMT but a medically trained EMT is the
driver is the person when all hands on
deck are
required can save that
life some might suggest that an EMR with
a very narrow scope practice is an
adequate substitute for fully trained
EMT I would beg to
differ what would you tell the patient
or their family that is put their trust
in you to provide quality care and save
them or their loved one but you didn't
have the appropriate staff person on
board to do
so our communities are putting their
faith in us and not hiring qualified
train staff is not what they expect from
us I do not believe that any potential
patient would support this bill knowing
that it will be themselves or their
loved ones at
risk I ask that you oppose House Bill
559 and honor the trust and faith that
our people have put in us this bill's
intention does not support best
practices and goes against State and
National
standards okay thank you representative
Maser and then representative Weber
thank you Mr chair thank you for my
question we heard that um during Co that
this was implemented so why would why
was it okay during Co and then not now I
think there were a lot of things that in
an auster situation and in an emergency
we permissible I don't necessarily agree
with that I think also he was speaking
from a more urban experience and I am
from a very rural area where distances
to hospitals is a lot longer and I think
having the quality care for that long
ride is
critical representative
Weber thank you and welcome to chesher
County day at
the at the health and human services in
elderly Affairs committee um I'm I'm now
in the uncomfortable position of having
to reconcile two of my uh respected
colleagues with opposite views
but we heard earlier well and and my
problem is I agree with everything that
each of you said so
that the choice is not necessary
between
um one one qualified person or two
qualified people
but not getting there at
all and coming also from chesher County
and one of the more rural parts of
chesher County
um how do you balance the issue of
wanting the two people
absolutely but maybe there two calls
that have come in at the same time or
three calls that have come in at the
same time how do you balance the issue
of not being able to render the service
and having to wait longer to render the
service so I live in bring we have an
ambulance service that is only staffed
from 6:00 a.m. to 6:00 p.m. if you have
a problem outside of that and they can't
get some volunteer to come get the
ambulance get a an EMT and get to you
there's a problem and that's what Mutual
Aid is for we call Peterboro we call
Fitz Williams we even reach down into
Massachusetts that's what a mutual Aid
agreement is for there is always an
opportunity to get help it may not be
directly from our ambulance service but
it is there and it's qualified Personnel
in the bus that's what we're that is
anyone else representative Castle ring
and then representative Palazo thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question so question specifically to the
timing that she just uh kind of said
with that are would where you live are
you comfortable with it taking longer
because of the time frame okay so I live
personally on a class six road that is
not Town maintained I own a tractor to
plow myself out I live 7 miles from our
an in our fire department that's a
reality we all live with speed is not
necessarily what's going to save
somebody's life Quality Care is what
saves life you can drive a taxi with an
injured person quickly but you may be
arriving with them dead because you
didn't have the skill set necessary to
unfolding representative
palazov thank you Mr chair uh thank you
for taking my question uh how often
those situations happen when uh the
driver uh has to jump back and help is
it like one per thousand rights or is it
one in a million okay if it's you what
would you
like just just asking a question because
we're asking our family and our
constituents to bank on the fact that if
they are the person in that ambulance
nothing is going to change with their
critical
condition on the way to the hospital so
that 1% could be you your wife your
children your
mother that's what we're asking people
to do is take that
chance now my husband was in a serious
motorcycle accident and nearly lost his
leg I want the most qualified person in
you anyone
else seeing no one else oh sorry
representative mlan yeah thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question so um so you mentioned um
because as representative Weber said
it's you're you're trying to assess the
different levels of risk um so do you
find where you have the the situation
that you have where you only have um an
ambulance service that staffs from 6: in
the morning to 6 at night um do you do
you find I just if I understood your
testimony correctly so I see your face
so maybe I didn't understand quite
correctly but anyways your the ambulance
service that you have available is not
24 hours correct was my understanding
correct and so um if you had this
available to you um would would that
allow you to be able to have a 24-hour
service um because you have more
flexibility um or are there other
constraints around that um or do you see
with the way you are right now in a
rural area that being able to even have
that service could potentially be in
Jeopardy because of the recruiting
problems that the sponsor talked about
especially in rural areas so where where
do you see those challenges in relation
to the
bill that's why we have mutual
Aid there is a town next door that'll
come if they're not available there's a
town next door that'll come I don't see
it as a problem to get an ambulance to
me what I see as the problem is having
the qualified people on the ambulance
when it
arrives follow
up so um so and just just to follow up
on that because you are so reliant on
Mutual Aid um in in the area that you're
in um as we get away from Co covid and
the recruiting gets higher and higher do
you see in your area some towns dropping
Ambulance Service all together to flip
to Mutual Aid because of Staffing
constraints or that has that not been
your experience so in our area we do
have chesher medical
we also have the Cheshire uh
EMS which we have contracts with 19
towns to either provide direct ambulance
support or Mutual Aid backup to them yes
there are towns that don't have their
own ambulance service or it's not
full-time they either use the Cheshire
ambulance to
supplement or they have a mutual Aid I
think most towns rural towns rely on
Mutual Aid I don't think there are very
many rural towns that can
24hour a day 7 days a week fully staff
more than one or two ambulances and at
some point if there's a critical
situation those two ambulances are going
to be out and you still will need to
call on Mutual Aid and I know it's
different for more urban environments
but rural environments do rely more on
life representative Weber and then
representative Woods is is it fair to
say that in chesher County we have the
full range from a professional
um uh professional firefighters staffed
uh Keen fire department that's
247 running all the way to any number of
towns that don't run an ambulance at all
no King doesn't go out that far that's
what the chesher um right I'm I'm just
talking about the different ranges of
stuff you have keen which serves itself
in the surrounding communities um and
then you have chesher EMS and then you
have a lot of towns that may have one
ambulance or you have towns that have no
ambulance and rely on their
neighbor yeah representative Woods uh
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question um I'm I'm in complete
agreement that we have to have the best
available upon arrival at any given
scene um but at some point would
you sort of admit that um someplace
along the way there may be a severity
that regardless of the training of the
ambulance but they're not going to be
able to provide that life-saving care
there there is a limit or I would
well is
it a driver and an ambulance both
EMTs I'll give you I'll give give you an
example um I'm I'm a I'm a physician and
I put in a lot of chest
tubes um say you said your husband was
in a motorcycle accident if he'd hit a
tree and collapsed his chest wall um he
wouldn't survive very long if he unless
he had a chest
tube but I I wouldn't think that any of
the
EMTs they're not qualified to do so in
other words there is a limit to which we
could expect care to be given and I
guess my question is where is that limit
well in that situation whether you had
one or two EMTs on that car you would
still need to have Advanced Medical Care
you'd still need the paramedics to come
and you'd probably need life support and
that wouldn't change whether or not you
had one or two people on there that's an
extenuating circumstance that of course
would require um a paramedic or hire
but I don't think that
speed is always the answer I think
answer anyone
you no one else else has signed up to
testify in this bill does anyone else
wish to
testify seeing no one I'm going to close
the public hearing on HB 550 9 our next
357 um and would it be appropriate
perhaps to go into an executive session
on one of the or is it too
tight okay all right we'll just be we'll
yeah we are going to um go into
executive session for house resolution
um chairman needs to get something
before we go too far on
everywhere okay representative merer
excuse me representative
palazov uh I I would like uh could
representative Weber you had a question
I was just going to point out that we
have a person who isn't here which I
hadn't realized but oh anyway we'll go
ahead representative plaz off I would
like uh to make a motion of an expedient
to legislate on house resolution
14 and is there a second second
representative we
seconds okay would you like to speak to
your motion representative
palaza uh yeah yes please uh uh uh yes
uh I I'm very
uh sympathetic uh uh to the idea of
trying uh um low lowering prices or uh
in increase uh
competition uh but um the were question
if resolution is a right vehicle for
this especially like taking uh some uh
um judicial uh decision
that was made uh relatively long time
ago and was not used in this regard or
by any other states and uh general idea
that
often in this legislature and another
bodies we
actually um create and protect some
medical institutions that are basically
uh have of enormous power and could be
considered
monopolies so uh uh first creating and
supporting them and then asking attorney
general to go and find them or otherwise
I don't think is a appropriate way of
action um those are General concern
personally me uh I have some additional
concerns uh uh with uh how antitrust
laws uh would be applied uh to current
medicine uh so for this reason uh I
think that this resolution is not ready
to be
adopted thank you representative Weber
did you wish to speak to you a second
just that I would I would I would Echo
that I think probably everybody who sits
on this committee is very concerned
about the price of and and availability
of healthcare and that's given for all
of us we may have different ideas of
what to do about that but um I agree
that this bill is not one of them and it
antitrust litigation is very complicated
very and uses an enormous amount of
resources um and so unless you are in it
for the long run and are willing and
able to devote enormous amount of
recesses resources it's it's not going
to be worth anything and I agree also
this is a resolution it doesn't have any
force and antitrust litigation in this
area is best done on a federal level
rather than a state level so for all of
those reasons I absolutely
concur thank you representative Woods
thank you Mr chair um I would agree with
everything has said so I'll be brief but
um I think and I'm being critical here
but um I think to resolve it very poorly
worded for the problem that we're facing
it's not couched in the correct terms
and it's not couched in a way that acts
to direct it uh for a solution um
admittedly there is a tremendous amount
of work that it needs to be done with
the corporatization of medicine um
what's outlined here this is not
properly directed and I I'm I I just I I
can't support it okay thank you thank
you anyone else before we go to the vote
okay motion is itl on house resolution
14 the clerk is ready I'll ask him to
call the
rooll rep merer
yes rep mlan yes rep
damus rep kofalt yes rep poov yes clerk
votes yes R marel yes rep McGrath yes re
kessing yes rep Weber yes rep McKay yes
rep Woods yes rep elberger yes rep TZ
yes rep lontine yes rep hartnet yes rep
Lucas yes vote is 18 to zero uh oh rep
McDonald yes vote is 18 to zero motion
passes if there's no objection we'll put
it on consent
perfect you got to the majority report
representative palaza okay uh with that
we have six minutes before our next
recess
e
okay welcome back um we now have before
us um and and representative Lucas thank
you for changing the
sign I I for all about that thank
you now we are now hearing uh HB 357 and
we'll recognize the prime sponsor
representative Jim
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee for hearing my
testimony for the record my name is Jim
kofalt I'm a state representative from
Hillsboro County District 32
representing the towns of Wilton Temple
and new IP
switch uh so house 357 will look
familiar to some of you who have served
on this committee uh in the last bium uh
this legislation makes a simple but very
important ch change to RSA 141
c20a that uh that statute mandates that
children in New Hampshire be immunized
against specific diseases and those
include diptheria MPS pusis polio
rubella rubiola and
tetanus this bill would not change that
uh what it would do is change rulemaking
Authority because the same RSA
authorizes the Commissioner of Health
and Human Services to add other
immunizations to the list of mandated
vaccines under that provision DHHS has
added three more vaccines um and and
this was quite some time ago so they
have not added any recently
um but they've added three more uh
vericella Hepatitis B and
Hib if this bill were to pass it would
Sunset those three mandates it would
leave them in place until their exp
until the expiration date of those rules
uh because because those rules expire
after 10 years um their expiration date
currently is uh June of
2026 um it would also revoke the
commissioner's authority to add any new
vaccines uh by rule so uh the idea would
be that if um if if the legislature
chooses to add additional mandates or to
mandate the three that are currently in
rule that would be done by a vote of the
people's elected representatives
um why is this important um it's
important in my view
because when we mandate any kind of
medical intervention that is an
extraordinarily serious ma matter I
believe that those kinds of mandates
should only only be implemented by The
People's elected
representatives um we saw a number of
attempts to mandate the covid vaccine
for example and although we rep
repeatedly heard the Mantra safe and
effective we now have considerable
evidence suggesting that the co shots
were neither safe nor effective uh that
continues to be debated and I am
guessing that it will continue be to be
debated for some
time generally speaking our state is uh
is pretty light on vaccine mandates um
so the the Commissioner of Health and
Human Services has been very very
restrained and has not added a lot of
vaccines to that list by rule um that is
not the case in other states where they
have quite a long list um having said
that I am still skeptical about some of
the vaccines um that are on the list so
Hepatitis B for example is an adult
lifestyle disease um the argument in
favor of vaccinating infants is that the
consequences of contracting hepatitis B
as a newborn um are quite profound
um nevertheless it seems to me that this
ought to be um the choice of um of
parents with the advice and and
recommendation of their of their doctor
to make that
decision um Senator ran Paul uh in a
heated debate over uh confirmation
hearings uh recently in the Senate um
questioned this this specific issue
questioned the the the timing of the Hep
B
vaccine um and so so I'm actually going
to read his his quote it's a it's a it
it was sort of spoken so it's a little
bit um you know it it's a little bit uh
not as fluid as I as I would like it to
be but what he said was why do I have to
do it as a newborn could I come back in
three months or six months so really
it's about
Choice it's about getting rid of
mandates it's about letting people
participate but it's also about the
government being honest what are the
risks and what are the benefits and they
haven't been honest about covid because
healthy children do not die from covid
do not get seriously sick and there's no
proof that the vaccine has any medical
benefit for healthy children so you know
it's notable that Senator ran Paul is
also a medical doctor his father was a
medical doctor um so he knows uh whereof
he
speaks his position and my position is
that this is a choice that should be
made by
parents um and that it is not something
that should be mandated under rule if we
do mandate it that should be done by the
people's representative so for me this
is a a uh very powerful example of a
matter of principle um that when we make
a very grave decision like a mandating a
medical intervention that that is
something that the people should have a
direct voice in through their
representatives so that ends my
testimony and I will be happy to take
any questions any questions for
representative kofo representative
mlan thank you uh Mr chair so um so as
as you mentioned in your testimony it
has been a very long time since we have
introduced a new vaccine through rules
and you know I I I understand your
reservations about the hepatitis B
vaccine but I do believe it's a safe
vaccine so um
would you be open to a compromise which
would say because right now we are in a
it's the vaccine debate is very
political and there's a lot of it's kind
of come to this place for a lot of
different reasons but would you be open
to basically eliminating the rul making
Authority but rolling these existing
ones into statute and amending the bill
in that way um is that something you
would consider I I would not support
that
um I I will tell you honestly I think
that vaccine mandates should be a thing
of the past and I think many people will
hear that and will be a bit shocked at
hearing that um but but here's why
voluntary vaccination rates are
extraordinarily
High um I I think that there you know
there there are compelling reasons to uh
to put this decision into the hands of
parents with the advice of their doctors
um
this bill does not attempt to roll back
any of the ones that are already in
statute um I just would would like us to
not see not see us add any additional
ones to statute given the very very high
rate of voluntary
vaccination I I I just don't see a
purpose for for adding those into into
statute other questions representative
lamon thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question
I'm just wondering about the scenario
where uh suddenly we do have an outbreak
of something that's potentially very
dangerous
MH and now in
order for DHHS to address it if the only
way that we could
Implement um a vaccine mandate to
address the problem is by going through
uh the state legislature that's going to
add a significant delay to that do you
have any any concern about that so thank
you for the question I would first say
that the rulemaking process itself is
not a rapid process so so that takes
time um the legislature by all means can
meet um can you know the speaker can
call the legislature into session at any
time if there is truly a pressing need I
would also say that there are other
tools at the disposal of the
Commissioner of Health and Human
Services
um for example um if there is if if if
there were an
outbreak um State Statute does permit
um the the commissioner to declare that
that students and children and child
care be excluded from attending their
school or Child Care Facility if they
are not vaccinated so that's in State
Statute that would be a tool that's
available to them um so I I think that
the um the assertion that uh we need to
make this decision for people um is is
simply
misplaced other questions representative
McGrath thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question
um are you aware of any children that
have died after getting
multiple injections all at
once thank you for the question um I
don't have direct knowledge of that I I
hear stories but I it's anecdotal so I'm
I'm reluctant to
um I'm I'm reluctant to raise secondhand
or third hand an doal information as as
part of this but but I I have I've heard
people say that I don't have hard
evidence of it other
questions yes representative elberger is
it thank you Mr chair I'm trying to
formulate this question so please
forgive me if I sort of stumble as I get
there one of your comments was with
regard to covid that healthy children
didn't get covid if I if I and please
tell me if I misinterpret that you did
misinterpret it I was quoting Senator
ran Paul if if you would like I can
reread the quote so we have it exactly
please
um he
said healthy children do not die from
covid do not get seriously sick and
there's no proof that the vaccine has
any medical benefit for healthy children
okay I'm concerned now because in
general people are healthy until they
there's a serious outbreak of measles in
West Texas at this point we've had a
couple at least one death I think maybe
two at this point those children were
not vaccinated and presumably until they
got measles they were healthy
children I'm trying to
understand
what the responsibility of us as
individual people
is to the people who surround us M if I
choose to not vaccinate my child and my
child gets sick and infects other
children is do I have any ownership of
that or is it simply well it just
happened I I'm really trying to
understand your take on this thank you
for the question so it's I'm actually
glad you brought brought up the the the
measles outbreak because I think there's
been a good deal of information that has
is um at best
misleading um it's worth pointing out
that um measles deaths declined 98%
between 1900 and
1963 before there was a vaccine
so you know simple steps like improved
nutrition improved hygiene brought us a
98% reduction it's also worth noting
that you know in 2025 um in the United
States we have 93 cases and of measles
and of those 93 cases the CDC lists that
95% of them were
unvaccinated or unknown vaccination
status so when I read something like
that it it it it gives me pause why is
the CDC putting out statistics that say
well 95 % were unvaccinated or unknown
status I I would appreciate if
institutions like the CDC would offer us
information that is
more
um more more helpful and informative you
I think they could just as well have
said the percentage that were vaccinated
the percentage that were unvaccinated
and the percentage that were unknown and
yet for some reason they saw it fit to
group two of those categories together
so it's these kinds of of things as as
um senator Paul
um indicated there there is a there's a
sort of skepticism that has developed
out there and I think that if we were to
put the information out there and let
people make decisions for themselves the
vast majority of people will continue to
have their children vaccinated according
to doctor's recommendations that is the
case right now and I think that there
are probably some people coming after me
who can site some of those numbers the
numbers I've heard range from um
somewhere in the mid '70s to the mid 90s
um depending on the vaccine and um the
the location under in question um but
voluntary vaccination rates are very
high um so the the the notion that we
need to mandate these things I think is
is
misplaced uh representative Lucas and
then representative mlan thank you Mr
chair and thanks for taking my question
um and I'm uh a retired physician I
OBGYN specialist so I will not speak to
the data on this because that's not part
of my background but uh I was wondering
uh be there's a quite a range between 70
and 95% vaccination rate voluntary
vaccination rate what is the level in
which um the population at large is
protected when uh a certain level of
immune Community is established or maybe
someone after you can answer that
question better um someone after me can
probably answer that question better um
however I will say that um you know
there are studies showing that uh with
the measles vaccine for example that her
immunity is is actually not achievable
because of the rate of vaccination
failure uh with with the measles vaccine
in other words the measles vaccine is
not 100% effective in preventing the
spread of the disease and I've even seen
uh information indicating that uh people
who have had the measles vaccine Can Can
Shed the virus for um up to 25 days or
or 30 days after receiving the vaccine a
followup um and then I was also
wondering about the rate of
hospitalization for non-fatal cases and
how that affects uh Public Health
expenditure
um from what I've read um as high as 10%
of children require hospitalization for
measles complications including
incilius um is that a
concern um I I can't speak to the
statistics I don't I don't know what
those statistics are but someone coming
after me may may have that information
thank you representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so um
we heard in your testimony that um you
know the voluntary uh vaccination rates
are very high you know it's my
understanding though from listening to
news stories and other sources that that
voluntary rate is being eroded a little
bit you know due to skepticism uh lack
of trust other things so um with this
bill um how do you see this bill playing
out you know in establishing
do you think it moves that trust
relationship in any way at all and do
you have any data that would maybe show
um in in states that basically mandate
through Ru making versus states that
mandate through statute is there a
difference in voluntary vaccination
rates um or you may not have that data
but i'' be interested to know if you did
have it just to kind of understand what
impact it has on trust and those
vaccination rates
thank you for the question so to the to
the second question I don't have
state-by-state
data as as someone previously noted
that's a wide range and it's a wide
range because among other things it's
describing a multitude of different
vaccines
um having said that I I
think we are moving toward a healthy
debate
about vaccination and its proper role in
healthcare its proper role in society
and the degree to which people um should
be afforded the the freedom to make
these
decisions with in in the context of an
informed discussion with their doctor um
so I I guess I see this as you know one
one of many measures that is sort of
moving us towards a a a Freer and more
open debate on the
topic other questions
you also signed up to speak are Colleen
Smith and Dr Benjamin Chan from the
Services you've asked for Combined total
good morning my name is Colleen Smith I
am the bureau chief for the Bureau of
Infectious Disease Control within the
division of Public Health services
within the Department of Health and
Human Services and today I'm joined by
Dr Benjamin Chan our state
epidemiologist and also an infectious
disease physician we are here today to
speak in opposition to House Bill 357
relative to taking um removing the
commissioner's rule making Authority
when it comes to child care and school
immunization requirements the department
believes that the current statute
provides a rigorous and conservative
approach that PRI prioritizes public
input protects parental choice and
carefully allows for expediency in times
of an emergent threat as was mentioned
before the commissioner's rulle making
Authority allows the commission allows
the department to be nimble in the event
of a public health response because if a
statute change was required to change
immunization requirements this could add
months to a process um the rule making
of process does allow public input and
as noted the commissioner has taken a
very deliberative approach historically
the last time a childhood vaccine was
added to the childhood and School
requirements was 2003 which was
vericella also there there is a lot of
background in decision-making that the
department is immersed in Daily with the
expertise required to make
recommendations when to add or remove
immunization from that schedule um
considerations are vaccine safety
vaccine Effectiveness the severity of
the disease and the likelihood of
transmission within the child care or
School
setting um also should note that there
are processes for exemptions either for
for a medical exemption or religious
allowed and the final point we would
like to bring up is that we also have
concerns about the removal of vericella
hepatitis B and the Hib vaccines from
the requirements for child care and
school um
admittance if this bill were to be
adopted New Hampshire would be the only
state in the nation that does not have a
requirement for Vell or Hib for School
attendance in only one of three states
to require Hepatitis B for for child
care or School
entry the department for this reason is
opposed to that um we also like to note
that we have seen a decrease in the rate
of immunization in over the last few
over the last few years and this is
especially concerning because there are
many people that cannot receive
vaccinations because they're either too
young or they're imuno compromised and
and having those around them being
immunized allows protection of all of
our children families and
Community um as was pointed out this
bill has been brought forward in 2022
and
2023 and because um and it was
deliberated at that time but you know it
it was determined that there is a a
deliberative approach um again want to
emphasize that it it's not something
that's commonly done adding or removing
vaccines to the schedle schedule and it
is important for us to be have that
nimbleness not only to include the
vaccine themselves as being um required
but also to determine dosages which is
done through the rule making process so
um in in closing we would like to hope
that you would find House Bill 357 in
expedient to legislate and we're happy
to answer any questions that you may
have thank you any questions
representative
Weber I was wondering if you know off
your top the top of your head or if you
could send them to us if you don't
because I certainly don't carry
statistics around my head um the uh
number of children if any who died of
covid uh and the number rate of
hospitalization of minors and when I say
children I mean persons under the age of
18 uh representative Weber State thank
you for that question I I don't know
that number off the top of my head it's
a relatively low number but we can
certainly get that to you
um I I will say I know that uh covid-19
keeps coming up uh the covid-19 vaccine
continues to continues to be uh
controversial and as we've said in the
past uh we have no plans of making the
covid-19 vaccine or the influenza
vaccine a required vaccine for entry
into school or child care agencies uh
you know we have never at the department
level made the covid-19 vaccine required
uh and we have no plans to do so um but
we can certainly get that information to
you I will just quickly add that
relative to um a prior statement um
about the severity of covid-19 in
children I I will say that uh you know
well uncommon covid-19 has contributed
uh to Pediatric deaths in New Hampshire
regionally nationally uh and it does
cause severe disease uh people may
remember uh multi-stem inflammatory
syndrome in children misc which was
newly described during the covid-19
pandemic um and actually the the age
group that was affected the most with
that syndrome with children 5 to 11
years of age um and many of them did not
have underlying medical conditions I
think the number if I can remember
correctly is 50% or more of children
with misc do not have um underlying
medical conditions so presumably we're
healthy children um so with all that
said though again we have no plans to
make the co9 vaccine a required vaccine
um for entry into school or Child Care
thank you follow up sure thank you thank
you so thank you so much and thank you
for taking my followup um do you know
off the top of your head what's the
number of kids uh
currently um suffering from measles in
the US
um those numbers are uh we could
probably quickly pull up on cdc's
website um there continue to be
outbreaks of measles at a at a national
level uh I will say relative to the
Texas outbreak I think the last um
update was a couple of days ago and
there were 159 children with uh
diagnosed with measles uh in the Texas
outbreak um and about I want to say 13%
of those uh had been hospitalized I
think this gets to another question that
was asked earlier
um including uh one one child that died
so these vaccine preventable diseases um
do cause significant disease and
morbidity and sometimes even death in in
children and that's the the purpose of
vaccines and vaccine requirements um I I
will also add that you know we
appreciate having you know a healthy
debate around um vaccine requirements
because there is this tension between
protecting the Public's Health which is
you know the Department's responsibility
uh not just protecting the health of the
individual but protecting the health of
people in congregate settings like
school and childcare agencies and that
includes protecting you know children
and staff that maybe are imuno
compromised or can't get vaccinated for
some reason and so that's that's part of
the the main reason why we have these
vaccine requirements is to protect the
health of the population in these
different settings where we know
infectious diseases can spread very very
easily
representative
delus thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
um actually I have two but I'll start
with this one so you mentioned uh
nimbleness and of course that's
important but if there's an emergency
and I'm just using CO as an example
because that you know came up and
everybody needed to get there whatever
they thought they needed um
if there's an emergency need for
vaccines how can you so I don't know how
to put this question to you how can you
say whether they're safe or not without
like trials and stuff so when as the
example our that we all went through
when covid came out and the and then the
vaccines were fast-tracked in and they
became available to to us
um you still couldn't say that for sure
whether they really were safe and and
effective so I I the nimbleness thing is
a is a kind of a problem for me on on
that and I I'd like an explanation of
that and then I have another question
but I'll wait for one question at a time
um uh thank you again for that question
representative it's it's a it's a really
um it's a good question and really
pertinent to this discussion and I think
there's a couple different um points to
make um
one is that uh no vaccine gets approved
or recommended without there being some
evidence and science about its safety
and efficacy that that includes the
covid-19 vaccine that came out in a very
short time frame there were um phase
three randomized controlled clinical
trials um backing up the um use of those
vaccines in the early days of the
pandemic both safety data and efficacy
data now
we can debate uh appropriately debate
whether that was sufficient data um but
there was Data there um that was showing
in the beginning that the vaccines for
most people were safe and effective um
the the issue became that um as more and
more science emerged uh some of uh some
of that data changed the efficacy data
changed we saw the vaccine efficacy
decrease over time um once the vaccine
was in use with millions of people very
rare complications and side effects uh
became more apparent that that you
wouldn't get from doing any sort of
clinical trial you know it takes
millions and millions of people being
vaccinated to identify um some of these
very rare events rare side effects that
occasionally happen um but there was
Data there in the beginning and as the
data emerged over time you know some of
the the messaging around vaccines um
changed but but this is exactly the
reason why you know the department did
not jump on on you know requiring a new
vaccine when there was still you know
limited data um but it's a it's a fair
point and a fair question that um you
know sometimes with with new vaccines or
new
immunizations uh the the the data and
the science does occasionally um change
over time and I think that that in
particular um has caused a decrease in
in confidence around vaccines so I I
appreciate the question but I do want to
um just say that there there is for any
vaccine that is is used
whether it's approved or under emergency
use authorization there is data looking
at safety and efficacy but sometimes as
the vaccine gets out to millions and
millions of people that more data
emerges you had another question or yeah
go ahead thank you Mr chairman
um I know that uh representative kofalt
also mentioned the fact that that the
legislature actually can be nimble as
well and um you are you aware that the
speaker can call the body back in for a
session if necessary and that actually
does represent the the people the
population of the
State uh yes and I would also point out
that there is also an emergency Ru
making process uh which also speeds up
the um the typical delays in um
administrative rules and so there is
that mechanism as well and so you know I
think our our um stance on this is that
the the rul making process still is a
quicker Pro more rapid process than you
know having to call back an entire
session of of the legislature I don't
know you want to add anything to that I
would just add that in the ru making
process you could add more detail
regarding doses as well it that wouldn't
have to be done through a statute change
and actually thank thank you for
reminding me of that I'm sorry to I
don't mean to um go on too long about
this point but you know the
administrative rules also serve that
important purpose that um vaccines
differ by the age that you give them the
number of doses none of that is captured
in the actual legislation RSA 141c the
details um to implement the law and the
requirements is found in the
administrative rules and so I think if
you did away with the administrative
rules that's going to potentially create
some conf confusion about you know so so
the measles vaccine is still required
what does that mean how many doses of
the measles vaccine at what age is it
required all those details are found in
the administrative rules not RSA
141c representative Maser and then
representative L
montin yes thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question would you believe
that this bill pertains to rul making
vaccines um I I I I think our um take on
this legislation is that it pertains to
both uh our one of our primary concerns
is the rulemaking authority um but the
secondary concern is that it it does uh
remove uh um vericella Hepatitis B and
hemophilus influenza type B or Hib when
the rules expire in 2026 so I think it
does both but I'm open to correction if
that's not the case thanks
representative lonan and then
representative Palazo thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question um
we have talked about measles quite a bit
and if I
understand this bill it
would not allow measles to be added to
the list
required um well it's not listed
in am I misreading it again is I don't
see I see D gyia months Ms huh oh
rubella correct okay thank you um but
while you're here could you elaborate a
little more on what are some of other
than death which is tragic but what are
some of the other uh serious
consequences to
um um a measles infection not just for
the individual but for an unborn child
and
during pregnancy yeah so so I think that
with with any number of these um you
know diseases there's potentially a
range of different uh complications that
can happen you know many will have a
more mild infection and go on to recover
but um both healthy and you know
children that might have chronic medical
conditions are at risk for more serious
disease um you know measles uh in
particular can cause um issues with
infections pneumonias I I I think that
that is leading to a number of the
hospitalizations for example down in the
Texas outbreak um you know respiratory
or um lung infections um measles and
actually many of these viruses and
bacteria on the um on the list um can
cause central nervous system infections
sometimes you know menitis or en sephtis
those are medical terms for you know
infection and inflammation in the brain
and spinal cord um you know of these can
cause you know congenital abnormalities
when a pregnant um mother is infected um
so you know it's not just measles but
this is the case across um all of these
diseases which have required
immunizations and is that is that they
can cause more serious disease um and we
have vaccines that are um highly
effective at preventing disease or
serious disease and that's that's part
of the reason why they're on the
required list
representative plaz uh thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question so from our previous
conversations my impression is that uh
Department uh uh when it uh relates to
treatment protocols or to vaccin
specifically is often relies on various
uh National medical boards or uh other
General Federal guidance so can you
describe your staff tasked with vaccine
safety and uh side effects and uh to
what extent your research of vaccine
safety is unique to New Hampshire uh and
New Hampshire data uh or is it more like
available um thanks for that question I
if I understood correctly it's about
that data around vaccine safety for New
Hampshire is that
correct yeah yeah colen Smith
specifically mentioned vaccine safety so
I assume that it means that somebody in
your department is looking into it but
um uh like comparing like how much you
rely on federal guidance and what actual
research you do in your department in
regards to vaccin safety and side
effects thank you for clarifying um so
so I think there's there's two there's
two aspects of of data um one are the
clinical trials that are done to study
vaccine safety and vaccine efficacy
those are not studies that are are done
for example in in New Hampshire or so
you know only in New Hampshire those are
those are large Global oftentimes Global
um studies that are conducted um and
that that is data that we certainly have
access to and review and so I think when
um Colleen was talking about you know
reviewing vaccine safety that that was
part of it you know we have access to
that data the data that gets published
the data that gets um presented before
some of these uh National um regulatory
groups like the FDA or the advisory
committee on immunization practices like
that's all public data um sometimes it's
presented earlier before some of these
groups than we have access to it um and
so sometimes we tune into these you know
National meetings where some of this
data is presented but that's that's
National and global data um that is
developed through through the scientific
process um the other side of this though
I think is um monitoring vaccine use um
and this gets to the issue of um systems
that are set up like Vees uh which I
think many of you may be familiar with
um the vaccine adverse event Reporting
System uh which is a federal system that
um
any any person that gets a vaccine and
then has an adverse event um whatever
the reason for that um whether or not
it's related to the vaccine that was
administered can be and does get
reported into the ver system um and so
that's that's where New Hampshire can
contribute some of that data um at a
state level up into sort of the national
um surveillance system for adverse event
monitoring um and every state does this
uh and it's actually a requirement of
Physicians to report or clinicians not
just Physicians but healthcare providers
who administer vaccines to report into
the system um certain um Adverse Events
that happen and and when you get that
data at a national level you have more
statistical power to be able to assess
whether you know rare events May Be
occurring and this happened for example
during the covid-19 pandemic um when we
uh at a national level were able to
identify um cases of myocarditis for
example that uh were associated with the
covid-19 vaccine um so so these kind of
monitoring systems become important uh
when vaccines are in use and there's
ongoing monitoring of uh vaccine safety
through these mechanisms so we don't
just rely on the you know pharmaceutical
clinical trials that are done we also
rely on these National surveillance
safety monitoring
systems representative Kastle ring thank
you Mr chair um question for you when it
comes to the because I've heard a lot
about rule making time frames could you
clarify how a new let's say thing would
get added to the list or what the
processes to get there maybe the time
frame so generally rule making can be uh
can be about a three to six month
process as Dr Chan mentioned earlier
there is an emergency rule making
process but that there so in those in
that month's time frame there is public
publishing of the Draft rules there's
allow there's allowances for written and
a public hearing to take public comment
and then ultimately the final proposal
is then presented to to Joel car to be
voted on and express any concerns or
objections at that
time follow so then in reference to the
the things that are taken out of here
that would be sunsetted um I guess the
question would be based on that um is
there any other states that do not have
these listed in their vaccine
requirements in the other
states so we can get you that data
specifically I can as as I mentioned
before New Hampshire if if uh vericella
was vericella or Hib were taken out of
the requirements New Hampshire would be
the only state that wouldn't require
those representative merer yes thank you
Mr chair um just quick question so I
keep hearing about
measles correct me if I'm wrong aren't
measles and German Measles in
statute correct okay thank
youor
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so um you know
I'm not an antivaxer and obviously I'm
very concerned about the fact as you
mentioned that uh the rate of voluntary
vaccination is going down so one of the
things that I like about this bill um is
that it's very trans arent I think the
house is very transparent and so I see
it as an opportunity to to build trust
and I think that the legislature can be
very Nimble and I'm thinking back to
Granite Hammer 10 years ago in the
middle of the opioid crisis where we
called a special session very quickly
and also it's my understanding that
prior to the ru making
Authority um everything had to be done
kind of through the statute because
that's what it was before so I guess I
just have two questions the first
question would be if we were 30 years
ago prior to this Ru making and we were
on the old mode which I think this is
basically what it takes us back to um
how would you envision you know a
granite Hammer type situation playing
out where we we had to move quickly uh
on getting something done um and where
would you see its adequacies and
inadequacies and um the second thing
would be um absent this
bill what do you see the department
being able to do to build that trust
because as you mentioned the trajectory
is down and I don't see the trajectory
going up so I'm just wondering what is
the department doing absent something
like this to to turn around to get that
voluntary vaccination rate up because
I'm very concerned about that so I guess
thanks so I I I can address I can try to
address the F the first part so I I def
I I believe that there are Pathways
certainly to cause to call an emergency
session if um an emergent situation were
to develop that required additional vac
vaccines or immunizations to be added to
the schedule I I think it's possible
um to debate I to debate the the the
logistics of it versus a rul making
process um I I I can't I'm not an expert
on on what that would entail um
certainly I would I would think it it
would be a lot more um it would take a
lot more resources to pull together a
larger body than than a than a smaller
body but to still to have that public
input deliberative process that and I I
do want to ALS also reflect back that it
this doesn't happen very often it has
been 20 thou it's been since 2003 since
uh an immunization was added to the
schedule the department takes that role
very seriously when making those
considerations so this would be an
emergent situation likely where uh a
situation to call together an eer either
emergency rule making or an eem
emergency session of of the legislature
yeah and maybe I can take on the the
second the second part of that thank you
for I you know I don't think either of
us feel that we're expert enough on the
convening of the legislature in an
emergency session to be able to really
um provide knowledgeable input on what
that might might look like um but
regarding the the second question you
know Public Health likes to operate um
on you know by getting voluntary input
whenever we can right I mean that that
is the preferred way whether you know
somebody has measles for example and has
to isolate at home we like to work with
a person with an infectious disease to
get voluntary compliance with isolation
for example um but at the end of the day
um we have seen vaccination rates
declining over the last several years um
exemptions increasing which will be
relevant for the the next Bills
discussion um and and the and our goal
and our job as the department um is to
protect the health of all people um in
public in the population and that there
is a role We Believe for having
immunization requirements for that
purpose and going back to what I said
earlier um not just protecting the
individual but protecting vulnerable
people who need to um be in these
communal spaces Child Care schools um so
that they can Thrive and be healthy and
get a get an education um it's important
to have a safe and healthy environment
and part of that is making sure that we
have the highest vaccination rates we
can for all people for the protection of
all people um and with declining
vaccination rates it sort of puts a
spotlight on the fact that one of the
ways to get the highest rates possible
is with these sort of selective vaccine
requirements for those diseases that are
most impactful and have the um and have
the the greatest efficacy from you know
vaccination
well and so again I mean and and I
understand you know the requirements and
and how they can get vaccination rates
but my question specifically was
relative to the the voluntary
vaccination rates um and is there is
there any active work being done by the
department Department aside from the
requirements to because as you said you
want to push the voluntary side as much
as you can so you know absent this bill
are there any active initiatives within
the department to tackle that maybe I'll
start and see if Colleen wants to add
but you know I think this is the this is
one of those areas where you know we we
keep going back to and need to rely on
uh a person's healthcare provider right
I mean at the end of the day there are
some people that don't trust government
or don't trust the department um and so
this is this is where um you know people
that have questions people that have
doubts about vaccines should discuss
those questions or doubts with a
healthcare provider um and you know if
people choose not to be vaccinated
against for example the covid vaccine
the flu vaccine which are not required
um then then that's their choice and
that's okay um but we continue to point
people back to their trusted Healthcare
provider as um a source of um
information to discuss you know
questions and concerns that they may
have um to you know increase voluntary
vaccines anyone
else representative
McGrath thank you Mr chair and thanks
for taking my
question you stated
that when these vaccines are
started there's trials and there's
safety
data and then you also
stated
that we still need to see millions of
people get vaccinated to really uh
monitor what's
happening my question for you is are you
aware of the thousands of pages of fizer
documents that they tried to keep hidden
for 70 years but we're ordered to
release that listed before the VAC covid
vaccine was released that listed the
myocarditis that we're just finding out
effects um so I have not seen those
documents um I I will I will say just to
clarify my earlier statement that there
are the sort of required formal studies
that are done before a vaccine is
approved these are like the the phase
one two three clinical trials and then
there are the
realworld studies that come out after
the fact um as vaccines are used they
continue to be studied uh there continue
to be these surveillance systems to make
sure that um the findings in the
clinical trials um bear out in real
world use and sometimes not always but
but sometimes that real world use leads
to additional findings that couldn't be
identified in the formal clinical trials
because those clinical trials are just
too small um so so it's not that um it's
not so I think there there's two
different sort of sets of data and
processes that happen um and the formal
clinical trials are what's used to get
approval and then recommendations and
then there's the real world monitor that
happens and this also points I think to
the importance of groups like The
advisory committee on immunization
practices or acip is that they routinely
meet meet to re to review and re-review
new data that's emerging to update
vaccine recommendations so vaccine
recommendations are not static you know
at one point in time um they continue to
get reviewed and updated and and
recommendations can change based on new
emerging science and data um and that
has happened with numerous vaccines um
over time and so if there's new data new
information that comes to light that is
incorporated into um the the review
process that happens uh and
recommendations can and in fact do
change um over time as new data emerges
but relative to your question about you
know the specific situation with fiser
and um data I haven't seen the
information that uh you're referring
to thank you anyone else before we move
also signed up to speak is Melissa
Hampshire oh
okay also signed up to speak
is Pam denapoli from The New Hampshire
minutes
15 thank you uh my name is pamon Appy
I'm a registered nurse from Manchester
and I'm a member of the New Hampshire
Nurses Association and New Hampshire
school Nurses Association and I
submitted my online testimony uh on
behalf of those members in strong
opposition to this bill so I didn't want
to reread that testimony so I just
wanted to say some of my personal
concerns so as a registered nurse I'm
licensed to protect the health of the
public HB 357 makes me question if I'll
be able to practice to the Fidelity of
this license because of the Clause that
says that the authority of the
commissioner to adopt rules would be
removed and it goes on to say that the
commissioner is the individual who may
best instruct healthc care providers and
the public in methods of pre prevention
and control of communicable diseases
including proper treatment and methods
so if I don't have that expert advising
my practice I'm concerned about my
ability to protect the public and given
the argument that the legislature could
be nimble and could respond um in the
absence of that rulle making it concerns
me that the second part of this bill
would eliminate vaccines that have
protected the public for many many years
including um Hep be vericella and Hib it
was referenced that Hep be is a
lifestyle um necessary for a lifestyle
but hepe since 19 prior to 1982 when
was required nurses every day were
faced with the risk of hepb from needle
sticks so what the hepb vaccine has done
is almost eradicated in infants and
children protecting those of us who are
in public public health and practice at
the risks that we take every day to
these vaccines a second concern I have
is a relative to veracel you had
mentioned Public Health expenditures to
hospitalization but we have to think
about when children used to get chicken
pox the number of days they missed from
school and the number of days that it uh
kept parents away from their jobs so it
was a it was both an economic and a
public health um problem when children
used to get Chicken
Box um so the the the idea that the
legislature will now make decisions on
what vaccines when the decision that
they're presenting is to eliminate these
vaccines that have been proven and safe
since 1982 so that's really a concern um
the portion of the this statute really
dismantles what public health
professionals have done for very many
years so the rule making of Authority um
really needs to stay with the experts in
the field and the process that currently
works so in my practice I need
knowledgeable good mandates that will
help keep my public save you could start
wrapping up ma'am that's it so that's
what I have to say okay thank you any
questions representative
paza thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question uh did I hear you
correctly that uh one of the reasons why
uh parents are encouraged to vaccinate
their newborns from hepatitis BS to
protect
nurses that that's been an off that's
been a positive from when was
started to be um mandated since
1982 as now as nurses were protected as
the those individual idual have grown
and have been
Weber would it be helpful to you or
reassuring to you to know that
the because I had the same concerns you
just expressed that with respect to rule
making Authority the only section on
rule making Authority that's being
removed
is
uh
c613 which so the only thing that the
commissioner is not being allowed to do
that they do now is uh add other
communicable diseases but that all the
other rule making Authority in the
commissioner stays in
intact I mean that it's helpful but
still I think that it has to be done by
the person with the best evidence and I
think that that's that's what you heard
prior is that is the Bureau has that
ability to make those good
recommendations for us
providers anyone else representative
mlan thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question so you know a big
concern I have obviously is is trust
with the public so that we can kind of
get over this uh skepticism that we have
because I think that vaccination is a
very important public health tool um and
I'm trying to think of ways to reverse
the trajectory and I think of this
because it's very transparent would
would give us some of that opportunity
so um and because I I'm not as familiar
with the rulle making Authority as maybe
you are could you maybe speak to us a
little bit about the relative
transparency of the rul making process
and the legislative process
and you know because I know that we're
accountable to to the voters and I'm
just trying to understand you know the
relative transparency and the relative
power that the public has Ru making
versus the legislature so I hope I
there's a question in there somewhere
right well I I think that the public has
the power to refuse vaccinations if they
want to that's not helpful to us as
providers but the the legislature to
take away the power that protects the
public for the individual who is
skeptical is not a good Power Balance is
what I would say so do you want to give
the Power Balance to the individuals who
are putting the public at risk or do you
want to give the Power Balance to the
providers who are protecting the public
follow up yeah thinkk I think that the
the Power Balance with the legislature
isn't so much with the individuals
because it's it's the whole whole of the
legislature so they are reflecting they
are reflective of the will of the public
maybe not just one skeptic um at least I
I think that's kind of how we operate as
a legislature and but again I'm not as
familiar with the rul making Authority
so I'm just wondering how the the the
the the the will of the people not just
the individuals is reflected in the
rulemaking authority versus A
legislature because that's not the part
as I'm as much I'm familiar with but I
do think that the legislature is not
accountable to one skeptic but the will
of the public as a whole so I think
that's what we would we would hope but I
mean I think that there's going to be
Skeptics on both sides of whether or not
the the body is really reflective of the
people or is it reflective of some
misinformation and rhetoric that we may
hear and I think the other thing is that
a lot of the skepticism and even the
argument here today was around Co
and we have to think about that these
other vaccines have been safe and
reliable and and would change the
vaccine mandates based on one EP
pandemic that we recently ex experienced
so I think that to to be transparent we
had vaccines prior to covid that we
didn't we didn't care about I mean we we
got them voluntarily as the word has
been said and now all of a sudden it's
that these these vaccines somehow are
against against the will of the people
so I think I think we move the
conversation away from covid and move it
back to Childhood Imus that have been
safe for many years and are protecting
the whole age Spectrum now because you
know what I got them when I was a child
and and it's protected me and now it's
protecting my child so you know I think
that we have to think about it that way
thank you representative Weber could I
ask a procedural question of you Mr
chairman would it be helpful do you
think for members of the committee who
are not particularly familiar with the
rul making process to get our researcher
to give us a memo on what the ru making
process is and how it operates so that
they could decide uh from somebody who
um has actual knowledge of it what the
process is and how how it works and can
judge for themselves how they feel about
it after that that makes sense I'll I'll
make that
request anyone else representative
damus thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question
um when you when you immunize your child
as an
RN I don't know who exactly speaks to
the parents about what these these
immunizations do um when they're
required in the whole nine yards but I
would assume that that the parents are
informed by an RN or by uh the doctors
who are experts I acknowledge certainly
an RN is certainly an expert um the the
vaccines that are being proposed to
being um removed from the list would
they not be spoken of at any rate by the
nurses and the doctors so that the
parent parents would have a full
spectrum of the immunizations available
for their children yes I mean that that
would be that's our role is to explain
that the vaccinations right so but right
now we sort of have the ability to say
this is what this is our best evidence
and these are the recommendations that
we make with our best evidence at this
point I would guess that a parent is
going to make the best decision also for
their child so if I say to them this is
what the CDC is recommending and this is
what New Hampshire is recommending this
is what you need prior to your child
going to school um and do these are your
options I'm I'm would give a parent the
credit that they would make the best
decision and I have to I think my point
around um my practice is if if if that's
not the best evidence that I'm getting
because I'm waiting for the legislature
you know would I would I be able to to
have that same Authority to recommend a
a vaccine does that make sense no it
doesn't look like it anyone
Hampshire thank you Mr chair members of
the committee uh thanks for you letting
me come back um I'm here today to speak
in support of HB 357 which seeks to
ensure that decisions about vaccine
mandates for schools and daycares are
made by elected representatives not
unelected bureaucrats this is not just a
matter of public health policy it's
about restoring accountability
transparency and most importantly
putting power back into the hands of the
people we all know that the legislative
process allows elected officials to
debate amend and vote on laws however
the rul making process is far more
opaque and more importantly done by
people who are not accountable to voters
this is where hb5 357 comes in it's a
simple but crucial reform it requires a
new vaccine mandate to be approved by
the state legislature not decided by
unelected officials this ensures that
decisions with profound impacts on our
children families and communities are
made in an open and accountable process
some critics May argue that the
lawmakers aren't experts in public
health and shouldn't be making these
decisions but this critique overlooks an
important part of the legislative
process elected official offals consult
experts in this case scientists health
professionals and the public before
making decisions public debates and
hearings ensure that multiple
perspectives are heard and considered
bureaucrats on the other hand make
decisions in secrecy without much debate
or
scrutiny HB 357 is not about vaccine
policy despite all the questions that
I've heard today it's about restoring
the principle that elected officials who
are directly accountable to the people
should have the final say in the matters
that affect our freedoms and rights this
bill guarantees transparency public
input and accountability in decisions
that impact the health and wellbeing of
our families now those are my prepared
remarks but based off of the questions I
didn't want to make this about mandates
because this bill doesn't remove any
mandates but mandates breed skepticism
good ideas don't require
Force that's it I'll take any questions
thank you any
questions representative palazov uh
thank you uh Mr chair thank you for
taking my question uh do you know
legally speaking are there other uh
Fields uh where department has uh rule
making authority to mandate certain
medication to the
population thank you for the question I
I do not believe so I think that this is
the only um type of medication that can
be mandated by through R
making anyone
Friedman you've asked for four minutes
if you could keep it closer to three I'd
appreciate
it uh Mr chair uh committee members
Aubrey Fred fredman I live in
Bridgewater I speak in support of this
bill so I was glad to hear that New
Hampshire is kind of conservative on uh
putting new vaccines on the school
vaccine schedule which is good but um
and I'm glad to hear that but I came
from
California and as we know this whole
it's a very political issue it shouldn't
be but it is and I'm telling you and I
can't this is before the whole Co thing
they were making it actually uh on their
uh for all schools not just government
schools private schools too everywhere
and the only people who were safe for
homeschoolers and that's not practical
for every family uh to be homeschooling
and so what choice do you have so it
really when it gets on the school
vaccine schedule it becomes like a
mandate for a lot of people it's not
it's really not uh if it were a
recommendation that'd be have a totally
different opinion on it uh but it's
pretty it's a it's a mandate basically
for most people and so it is a big issue
and it should always be between the
parents and the pediatricians to make
the decisions to vaccine or not and by
the way not just uh vac vaccinate or not
because uh the parents might not be an
antivaxer and they might uh feel well
okay yeah you know certain vaccines with
be good and maybe certain ones they
don't want to you know pick and choose
type of thing where you don't get that
once it goes on the schedule you know
the rule making they put it on the
schedule and it's uh you don't really
get much choice in it I mean I know they
have the exemptions but again in
California they were uh making it that
actually they went after the doctors to
uh if they gave out too many medical
exemptions they would go after their
license and threaten them
so and the and they were turning down
religious exemptions so again it's very
political and if you just got back to uh
having it be voluntary and then uh
people would recommendations I guess
that's the key key to it but they're not
recommendations they're basically
mandates and I was going to uh I'll pass
out my backup but this thing I'm sure
you remember during the co thing uh uh
that Dr Eric Rubin you know when they
were deciding about the 5 to 11 year
olds if it should be authorized and his
comments and so I put a little blurb in
here people said that was all taken out
of context but basically he said that
you know I don't and this was a
thoughtful person it's a doctor he's one
of the FDA committee members I I don't
really know wrapping up okay sure and
anyway he he went ahead even though he
had his out he went ahead and uh and
recommended any with all the other
people so the experts they don't really
know it should be between parents and
and the pediatricians and that's it
thank you thank you are there any
questions seeing n thank you thank you
I'm sorry representative R did you have
a question or no I was I was wanting his
WR
T here it comes okay all right
okay thank you also signed up to speak
lorri uh thank you for letting me
testify today my name is Robert Lori I'm
from
Danville I'm testifying on behalf of
myself and as a parent who's been
through that process of trying to get a
child into a school where there were
rules requiring vaccinations and I
brought as a reference today a book by
Robert F Kennedy Jr called vax versus
unvaxxed with um as you know he's been
recently appointed as
the United States
um head of Health and Human Services I
just want to read a little expert ex
sorry excert if I may from the
book uh it says since the enactment of
the 1986 National childhood vaccine
injury act which provides a liability
shield for vaccine
manufacturers I want to read that again
which provides a liability shield for
vaccine
manufactors vaccination schedule has
multiplied considerably today children
following the CDC recommended
vaccination schedule receive a minimum
of 73 shots for 17 different diseases
with the whopping 28 injections by their
first
birthday at a two month well baby visit
an infant may receive as many as six
vaccines for eight different
diseases um and he goes on there's a lot
of charts and interesting information in
here and he charts out all the um
statistics of vaccinated versus
unvaccinated
and overwhelmingly the children that are
vaccinated per the CDC schedule are much
more unhealthy than the children that
are not
vaccinated
so as a parent I don't think it's
unreasonable for me to be skeptical of
these
vaccines um they're a profit center for
the big pharmaceutical industry and they
have no liability and I think you're
probably make a prediction that there's
going to be a lot of litigation in the
near future particularly with RFK Jr in
charge of Health and Human
Services bringing to light as
representative McGrath pointed out
there's a lot of information they're not
giving us so I would feel a lot better
as a parent possibly a
grandparent
um that in the future we not subject to
these rules because as a parent as I
said having nav tried to navigate this
you're very
powerless against the bureaucracy to
deal with these rules that basically
would took us months to find out that
the requirements uh our daughter school
was trying to make were just arbitrary
rules and not requirements that's it
thank you okay thank you are there any
representative palazov uh thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
so when you were receiving giv
communication uh from your child school
or from
pediatrician uh did they
mention any of those scientific data
that is me mentioned in this book about
uh High rates of uh immune disease in
vaccinated kids or did they want you
about side effects uh for nervous system
or any anything else
well we were dealing with the school and
not directly at the time was in
Massachusetts not directly with the
health department of Massachusetts so
the rules came down from Health
Department to the school and the school
is saying well it's a
rule so as a parent there's a whole
bureaucracy above you which is powerful
and it's as a individual it's very
difficult to deal with
that yes my represenative elberger thank
you Mr
chair you referenced uh some comments
from uh Mr Kennedy about uh
liability and that pharmaceutical
companies are held harmless from
liability is that correct
correct if we say that pharmaceutical
companies should be um not it should be
held
liable for
issues relating to problems with their
products would you also then say that
families who choose to have their
children not
vaccinated and whose children then
infect other people causing them serious
harm should those families be held
liable for the harm to those children
whom they or their children hurt
uh that's a good question I don't know
how to answer that I'd have to give it
some thought but
um it's a parental decision based on
risk
assessment
um these vaccines are not without zero
risk and just from my own experience
growing up having received several
vaccines I think I got three when I was
in school and then noticing the Next
Generation that came along they're
significantly less healthy I mean when I
was growing up we never heard about um
autism it's that's a new word wasn't in
the
vocabulary and I was shocked to see the
children um through the 80s and 90s and
into the 2000s that had asthma and
allergies I mean allergies for things
which when I was growing up nobody had
these
allergies follow up follow up thank you
I it's also worth noting that our our
lifestyles have changed there have been
significantly increased rates of obesity
both as adults and as children uh that
we're putting many more additives into
our Foods than when I was growing up you
have a question representative and I'm
wondering whether you see that those are
vaccines there is evidence in the book
um it is coincidence
that with this vaccination schedule um I
would quote hypocrates who said it's the
dose that makes the poison I
think as I said we were vaccinated for
several different diseases polio
probably tetanus I don't remember them
all but there's a too little and there's
the right amount and then there's too
much and I'm pointing out the fact that
right now it's too much and I really
would like not to see it get to be
anymore
thank you Mr chair representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so this bill does
not eliminate vaccine mandates okay so
the vaccine mandates stay the only thing
that this bill does is it's going to
pick which lane you go down in order to
arrive at are we going to have a vaccine
mandate or not so with that in mind some
of the the drugs that we have were
approved the old way some of them are
approved with the rul
making if we were to go to a
situation where this bill was to
pass and now we're approving vaccines
the same way we approved them 30 years
ago would you be more inclined to
vaccinate your children or would you
I would ask if a doctor recommended a
vaccination a particular vaccination
rather than I mean right now there's
kind of
blanket recommendations and I think a
lot of people just go along with it
particularly because they don't have to
pay for it I would wager that 90% of the
people that got the multiple covid
vaccines if they had to pay for it
themselves would say no I'm not paying
for this so just quick follow up so just
to clarify y because I'm trying to
understand and getting at this idea of
voluntary compliance if you knew that
the path was not one of Ru making but
the path was one that the legislature
debated would you be a person that would
say okay these are the mandated drugs
for my children to get into school and
I'm comfortable I'm more comfortable
with this passing the other one so I'm
going to comply so would it would it
make you Mr chairman I'm going to point
of order okay point of order this bill
is not about voluntary compliance the
bill is
about how we make rules and it seems to
me like we're getting fairly far away
from the actual substance of the bill
and we still have a number of people to
be heard and we're already 20 minutes
over time and I wonder
if this is actually relevant to this
bill or
not I I'll give you a quick answer the
answer is yes I would feel better if it
was legislated rather than it came down
as a rule from the CDC of the Department
of Health thank you and and thank you
and and and I I I respect uh the members
point of order the reason that I was
asking the question is because uh the
gentleman had mentioned that he had
tried
to kind of work his way around because
it was a mandate and he was trying to
work his way around it and so I was just
wondering um representative Weber if if
this was established would he try to
work his way around or would he just
comply and I was just trying understand
that it doesn't change my point of order
thank you hey anyone else before we move
you also signed up to speak is Christine
arau from the the pediatrician
representing the New Hampshire American
Pediatrics you've asked for up to five
minutes if you could keep it to three i'
appreciate it absolutely um I submitted
some online testimony so I'm going to
try to be brief thank you for hearing my
testimony today my name is Dr Christine
Arno I'm a primary care pediatrician
here in conquer I'm the vice president
of the American Academy of Pediatrics
New Hampshire chapter and um I'm
speaking on behalf of myself and the
chapter we strongly oppose House Bill
357 um and I do want to start by saying
that this bill is so alarming to
pediatricians across the country that um
the AAP National actually reached out to
us we our state chapter had already
flagged this bill as something we wanted
to make sure that we opposed but the
national headquarters reached out to us
just to make sure that we were aware of
it they represent 70,000 pediatricians
in all 50 states and this Rose to their
attention
um many of the reasons why are similar
to the what the Department of Health
said removing the flexibility to add new
vaccines based on emerging Health
threats or scientific
advances um we're all aware of the
measel outbreak and that infectious
diseases outbreaks are still out there I
understand that measles is a vaccine
that would still be recommended um but
I'm just using that as an example of
something that people didn't worry about
10 years ago um and now have to um we
are getting a lot of calls at our office
here in town worried parents
about that measles outbreak um again I
submitted written testimony so I am
going to try to just speak to some of
the um things I've heard here today one
thing that keeps coming up um that I
keep hearing is um that many vaccine
preventable illnesses um are not as
impactful for otherwise healthy
kids and I think that um what I want to
say about that is that sometimes they
are sometimes otherwise healthy kids do
suffer severe consequences from these
vaccine preventable illnesses and also
that not all kids are otherwise healthy
kids so our job at you know your job as
legislators is to protect all kids right
my job as a pediatrician is to protect
all kids um and there are some children
who are extremely vulnerable either
because they are too young to be
vaccinated or because they have
underlying health conditions that
prevent them from being vaccinated if we
do not require these vaccines in the
schools children may attend school bring
an illness to the school and then
another child can bring that illness
home and affect a sibling who is
vulnerable and not able to be vaccinated
so we have to work together to protect
all children another thing to keep in
mind is that um nationally 90% of
parents vaccinate their children on
the regular recommended schedule so that
is really the majority and I think
sometimes we can forget about that and
feel that we're not representing the
majority if we recommend these
immunization immunization schedules okay
so um the other thing I just wanted to
say is um Hib hemophilus influenza one
of the vaccines that is recommended to
be taken off um this vaccine was
introduced 34 years ago so I'm just
going to briefly share a colleague story
because I don't actually I've never seen
a kid with severe disease from Hib my
colleague Dr Patricia Edwards did her
residency in the 1980s and shared with
me a story of um a young boy who
unfortunately died went so rapidly from
being a healthy child to passing away
that his father was in disbelief and was
um asking the medical team where the
child was was sure that he must be
hiding somewhere because his um descent
from healthy to unfortunately dead was
so rapid um Hib is a very dangerous
disease it's a bacterial illness um it's
not the flu Hib is hop influenza
bacteria it can also cause epiglottitis
which can lead to Suffocation of a child
if not treated rapidly with a breathing
tube and IV antibiotics thank you for
listening to my testimony please oppose
vote inexpedient to legislate for House
Bill 357 which threatens the safety of
newer children thank you I'll take any
questions yeah representative Lucas
thank you thank you Mr
chairman thanks for for taking my
question um I earlier on I had a
question that wasn't answered um and I
was wondering if you might be able to
provide the statistics on the rate of
hospitalization of children who are
infected with measles the rate of
hospitalization for measles I believe it
was um in the current Texas outbreak
it's about
133% thank you yes and one point about
that that I just wanted to some people
so we actually try to avoid
hospitalizing children with measles if
at all possible because it is so very
contagious so really children are only
Hospital hospitalized with measles if
they are very very sick um so those
rates may actually seem lower than you
would expect because of that follow
follow uh could you define very very
sick um requiring IV fluids requiring IV
antibiotics for a secondary infection
such as a secondary pneumonia um those
would be my require ing breathing
support such as a breathing tube for a
secondary pneumonia those would be my
examples yeah thank you anyone else
representative CLE R thank you Mr chair
so quick uh looking at the your your
argument here the rules that would
remove these items specifically or these
uh conditions let's say um is the
argument that you are concerned about
but the other argument is who has the
authority to make these rules what is
your stance on that specifically in the
medical field
um I believe that the public health
experts who have trained in the arena
you know have degrees in public health
have gone to school for this field are
more appropriate to be making decisions
about public health matters for you know
I think it would be somewhat silly to
ask Dr Chan to make a decision about the
roads in conquered you know but in in
his expertise or in the expertise of the
Department Public Health is what they
have studied for their whole lives and
so I think it is most appropriate for
them to be making those decisions thank
you representative
McGrath thank you Mr chair and thanks
for taking my question one thing I never
could understand
is we give babies one food at a time how
is it that we give them six
immunizations at the same
time so I think you know one thing that
has been really helpful for me as a
pediatrician I also have three children
and that experience really shaped so
much of my understanding of parents
um fears and you know I understand that
it can seem overwhelming to um take an
action to give a vaccine rather than
sort of sitting back and really hoping
that your kid doesn't get sick that
feels like an inaction and and can
sometimes be easier to swallow but but
the truth is the reason we give those
vaccines to young babies is because that
is when they're the most vulnerable
um babies die from from these illnesses
whereas you know 12 15 year olds maybe
have they're a bit hardier they're a bit
stronger um they're not as vulnerable
but little babies are really vulnerable
to these diseases and that's why we have
to protect them early um and so I can
understand why parents feel worried
about that process but if you look at
the data and you really consider what
the risk is of not immunizing those
children the the it it is very clear to
me that immunization is the safer Choice
thank you anyone else one quick question
one rep representative elberger thank
you um do you know of any drugs that
have no side effects no negative side
effects no thank
Condon thank you um my name is Laura
Condon I'm from Bedford I'm a volunteer
New Hampshire director of advocacy with
the National vaccine information center
and we work to educate and inform and
assist the public with information about
vaccines vaccine requirements and their
rights under the law we assist those
who've been injured by vaccines and I've
also served as five years as public
member on the board of directors of the
vaccine Association and I have and maybe
I'm the only person in the room who's
been through the rules process when it
comes to vaccination and now I'm going
to go off my script here because I think
there's important points here made that
need to be corrected you need need some
more information um number one this bill
is not about vaccine mandates whether
you should mandate or not this bill is
not about the merits of particular
vaccines this bill does not remove any
vaccine requirements in including the
three in rules this bill is simply about
who should
decide what vaccine mandates there
should be should it be the legislature
with all you people and all us people a
very public very thorough very open
process or should be be the very closed
exclusionary process of rulle making
without public input and I can tell you
you do not have public input there so
that's who should decide and I think
that speaks to representative mlan
you've asked the question over and over
again how can we build the public trust
and confidence in what our Public Health
authorities are recommending requiring
and when you shut shut out the public
when you shut out parents concerns when
you censor them you you undermine public
TRS 100% this really needs to be a
legislative process and let me remind
you that the V seven vaccines listed in
statute they were put there by the
Legislative process by people like you
by people like all of us who've
testified today they put seven vaccines
in statute they did that they could had
more um so I will tell you um yes
voluntary use is very high um someone
asked if they were aware of any children
who've died from vaccines I'm going to
give you a name his name is Ryan Johnson
he was 15 months old perfectly healthy
child from nashille New Hampshire I know
his parents um very well and I feel
comfortable using his name they've
testified here before he was only 15
months old given rud routine
vaccinations given a clean bill of
health and he was dead just days later
after receiving five routine
vaccinations yes there are real children
in New Hampshire who die following
vaccination um measles um are are are
not killing um healthy children we see
with this measles outbreak those
children that are being hospitalized and
large please startop wrapping up there
are children with underlying health
conditions and for for quarantine
reasons the rules process is please ask
me questions about that if you're not
familiar with it it is a closed process
jel car has taken the position over and
over and over again that the public has
no right to speak about for or against
any of the rules that are proposed by
government bureaucrats thank you ma'am
and in fact government bureaucrats did
impose covid shot ma vaccine mandates on
children and Foster families and this
legisl
had to pass statute to protect those
families from covid vaccine mandates so
somebody thinks covid vaccine mandates
weren't imposed they were and they were
done through rule making thank you ma'am
happy to answer any of your questions
any questions representative
Palazo thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so you you
mentioned the importance of public uh
input but um uh opion of this bill also
sometimes uh talk about um uh being able
to make some uh uh impartial decision uh
not being affected by self-interest so
comparing uh Department of Health and
Human Services and
legislature uh so Department is supposed
to be nonp partial believing in science
believing in vaccines but uh in
legislature people can have different
beliefs somebody can believe in natural
immunity somebody may be having a
business selling some vitamins so
there's a concern that legislature is
more self-interest or less less
impartial could you comment on that yes
I think the impartiality is an important
point there and let me share with you
something that that has changed over the
years when those seven vaccines were put
into statute by folks like you um DH HS
was not in the business of purchasing
all the child vaccines in the state
doctors can no longer purchase their own
inventory and 2002 the commissioner of
DHHS DHHS went into the vaccine business
in partnership with the vaccine
Association so and they receive hundreds
of do hundreds of millions of dollars
every year from the CDC as an incentive
for high vaccination rates the amount of
vaccines they purchase they are not no
longer in impartial body for determining
vaccine requirements because they have a
financial incentive in the number of
vaccines that are that are turned
through um the state here New Hampshire
and that what changed in 2002 so I think
it's important that we now look at that
change and say isn't it appropriate for
us to go back to what the legislature
did perfectly fine when they put into
law the seven vaccine requirements there
that are in statute any other
questions representative Woods
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question you mentioned the
15-month-old to had the number and uh
you quoted that he subsequently died yes
um he subsequently died uh is there an
autopsy report published stating that in
fact it
was because of uh because uh there's
been a fair amount of data from that
same agency uh that there's been some
separation between following and
causation
uh well Mary right um thank you for that
question Dr Woods um I I've gotten to
know this family very well I've read
their medical file on their son i' I've
read the autopsy report on and
unfortunately they they miss the the
statutory cut off for claim in the
vaccine injury Compensation Program for
the death of their child so they could
not get it proven through that Federal
program and the cut off was is they were
looking for genetic testing from a heart
specialist that was the one last thing
they need to rule out of what might have
caused other than vaccines their their
son's sudden death a perfectly healthy
child um and that eventually was ruled
out we missed the statute of limitations
for it to get you know to be proven in
the vaccine injury Compensation Program
um but his medical record is very clear
thank you representative kessle ring
thank you Mr chair I want to be quick
with this question so you mentioned I
heard before from the Department that
the heing is required under rulem you
said you had experience in ruem can you
elaborate more on what you just said
about it not being part of the process
versus what they said thank you
certainly I've had many experiences in
the rule making process when it comes to
to vaccines not just one the department
will hold a public hearing where you can
go in and you could testify on their
proposed rules and provide them with
input and they will consider your
input I'll be candidly that that's a
joke um you know they might modify a
word here or there really and I've seen
the the public fill their Auditorium and
really there's no material changes made
to their rules but that is you know what
they consider the public hearing that is
not jail car then when you go before a
jail car which is a committee of state
senators and state reps to listen to the
rules I am told repeatedly that I I'm
only speaking on their good graces I
have no statutory right to speak to the
jail car committee and most most of the
public is shut out I I've been allowed
to speak but I've seen the public
otherwise totally shut out on this um
and that um if the commissioner under
New Hampshire law has authority to
mandate vaccines that Jael car has taken
the position they have no authority to
tell him no he can mandate whatever
vaccines he wants including Co shots
anything other mRNA vaccines that
they're now bringing to Market to
replace traditional vaccines they have
no authority to tell him no because the
statute gives him the authority that's
what we're seeking to change is to
remove that Authority so that the
decision making on vaccine mandates goes
back to all of you all of us including
the doctors and nurses that testify here
including Dr Chan and his colleagues
there at dhh who testify here no one is
cut out of the legislative process like
they are through R making thank you
anyone else final question
representative Lucas thank you Mr chair
i' I'd like to Circle back to something
you said about the vaccine Association
and the financial incentives that are
coming down from CDC I think you said um
it was my understanding and please
correct me if I'm wrong that the vacine
association is a clearing house and they
use the money to buy the vaccines in
bulk in order to save patients and
practitioners the cost of buying them
independently um I guess I don't
understand what the incentive is if the
if the money is passing through and
they're not retaining
it thank you for the opportunity to
clarify those
misunderstandings um and I I served on
the board of the vaccine Association for
five years I've been attending their
meetings for probably 15 years so I know
them pretty well they are in partnership
with DHHS the way that that program
works is that DHHS comes to the vaccine
Association and says we're going to you
know purchase for $40 million worth of
vaccines this year that's about what
it's up to now and your share to cover
the cost of insured children is say
going to be 25 million I'm just picking
some round numbers here for you and so
During the period of the year the
vaccine Association assesses commercial
insurers to raise that money so in the
following June they have the money in
the account to write a check to DHS for
those vaccines that DHHS has already
purchased all year long DHHS is the one
that purchased the vaccines not the
vaccine Association DHHS purchase their
vaccines from the
CDC using the federal vaccines for
children contract and that's where they
get that discount as a compared to you
know a providers who get a much better
discount through their if it was done
privately but that's how they get theirs
and because they're buying from the CDC
they have to um you know take um pass
down to them all the CDC rules and
requirements and the C DC also gives
them millions of dollars in Merit based
grants based on their volume of vaccine
purchases to run their vaccine program
and I knew this to be true because when
I served on the board it was Marcel
babinsky at that time who was
represented from the Department of
Health and Human Services and she
bragged that that immunization
Department wasn't costing anything I
said how do you pay your employees and
she said well we get money from the CDC
the federal government and thank you so
I I went and looked up that that grant
funding thank you for your testimony
set uh we will not be taking a FAL lunch
uh in order to try to stay as close on
schedule as possible obviously we are
overtime on this bill and we still have
a couple of folks left and we want to
try to again stay as close to the time
time frame a lot it as possible so next
up uh so members can go to lunch at that
convenience uh next up is Kate fry from
new
Futures thank you sorry thought you
forgot about me before lunch my name is
Kate fryan the vice president of
advocacy at new Futures new Futures is a
nonprofit nonpartisan organization that
um works on health and wellness
throughout the state of New Hampshire
through policy change through this role
we work with policy makers Healthcare
Providers and communities to make um the
grand state as healthy as possible um
I'll just be very brief I have written
testimony just again saying when
children receive all recommended
immunizations on time our whole
Community benefits higher vaccination
rates help create Community immunity and
also policies and regulations help
communities ensure that all children get
the opportunity to grow up healthy and
safe and families can participate in
life activities and parents Miss less
time away from work so it's good for our
economy too but to get to the the point
of the bill that's come up a few times
is on Ru making in my previous life I
did write rules for the division of
Public Health Services and another
agency and so I think the recommendation
of having a very detailed um Memo from
the office of legislative services that
oversees the rule making process for the
state is an excellent idea and I just
want to clear up a few things when I was
trained on rul making I was told what
the law does the think of it as in terms
of maps almost it's the satellite
version of where you want to go the very
high level version and then the rules
are almost like the detailed GPS turn
right turn left turn right turn left and
so traditionally and you will find this
across all agencies is that rules are
very specific especially with something
like this rule when you talk about the
number of doses when you talk about the
number of timing you need that detail
specifity in rules it doesn't fit as
well in law the other thing I want to
say is there is legislative input for
The Joint Committee legislative
administrative rules that's the name
there are legislators on that committee
um and so as you heard there are 3 to
six months to have the rules um go
through sometimes longer um depending
how the public comment period um the
amount of revisions the department has
to make they are all reviewed by the
lawyers of office of legislative
services and then the legislators on The
Joint Committee of administrative rules
then hears those rules one of the
conditions for Ru making for a rule not
going through is um if there's a
tremendous amount of public comment
against the rule it's been a while since
I've written rules but that was the
process that um I remember when in my
rle making days but again I do think um
a memo or something from Office
legislative Services would be helpful in
understanding that road
map and that's all thank you very much
any
questions representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so just just from
your rulemaking experience if this bill
was to become law um am I correct in
understanding that the ru making would
still exist the GPS portion would still
exist except now the satellite portion
instead of coming from 8 HS a satellite
portion that would be the part that goes
back to the
legislature uh that could be the case
but I think what what is really tricky
with this rule is it with this
particular issue is that there's there's
very specific regulations of Doses and
timing and things like that and so you
would need that road map I think and it
would be very different from other
agencies who have similar rules like
this it'd be a very different
process follow up so I again though but
just to clarify if this bill passes that
would still that would be that part
would be unchanged the only thing that
would change is just which drugs to have
but the dosage and the the frequency and
you know the delivery modalities all
that stuff even if this passes would
still be in Ru making corre I think you
I don't read it that way I think that
would all have to be in the law I'll
look at it again but I don't read it
that way you're welcome any other
questions representative
delus thank you Mr
chairman so we do have the RSA right now
that at this point does require the
diptheria and the Ms and all of these
different
vaccines
so that was done by the
legislature so if the legislature has
the power to do that why is it not able
now to decide whether whether or not
these other uh vaccines that are being
removed from the
list have control over that I mean it
would be it it just makes no sense what
you're saying because we the the
the aren't the vaccines that are
required right
now don't they have a little road map
how much you give how much you do in
rule they do in rule in rule they do
okay follow up
so if the legislature is going to take
back the power and have the people
involved in in in figuring out what's
best as far as
the
immunizations that would be
prescribed where they go if they don't
they don't have to
be mandated
basically and certainly the doctors that
take care of the the parents and the
children could decide you know if the
and recommend to the parents what their
children should get doesn't it make
sense that we would continue that as the
legislature being able to uh determine
what would go into the statute that
already exists I think what I understand
your point thank you for the question I
do think though what you have to keep in
mind is the detail of the doses and the
ages and that would have to be in law
too all right any final questions being
York thank you Mr chair and members of
the
committee uh I didn't do my homework and
I did not look at uh the rules of the
rule baking committee and who's on the
committee and what sort of background do
they have but I think representative
Weber made a very good suggestion that
all the members that are gathered around
this horseshoe table really to ought to
study that and really determine how that
takes place on what's behind it all so
thank
you uh my concern is that the current uh
recommendations that come out of HHS
are reflective of uh CDC um and I think
the CDC in the last five years has taken
a lot of Wrong
Turns um I I I I they've really um in
number of cases have given advice that
was turn out to be
wrongful uh they have on their list of
recommended vaccines a number of ones
that aren't required for school
admission but uh the nonsensical
inclusion of hepatitis B for a newborn
baby uh I can't wrap my head around that
as one they have a few others
HPV uh which is a pretty dangerous
vaccine
historically uh it's a recommended not
required uh the covid shots for children
and newborns uh absur I mean children
should get covid and develop robust
natural immunity be exposed to the whole
virus not just the dangerous Spike
Protein that's
nonsensical so I worry that some of
these other vaccines would get on the
schedule for the required School uh
School
admission um in closing I would just um
add that our state epidemiology olist
said that he has no plans to add covid
to the required shots but the fact that
uh they have the power to do it if they
so decide worries me very much so leave
those decisions to citizens of the New
Hampshire who are able to come here and
testify they're able to bring uh
national International experts to the
table to testify on occasion uh so
please support uh HP 357 thank you thank
you
uh representative plaz off and then
representative Lucas uh thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking uh my
question you mention uh hepatitis B
vaccine for newborn children that maybe
doesn't make sense but we we heard
testimonies that nurses are very afraid
uh of persons who are not vaccinated
from Hepatitis B uh could you comment I
don't fully understand why they're
concerned if they can be vaccinated
themselves uh but uh what's your uh I
agree with you 100% there's been other
questions about what if my unvaccinated
child has a measles and then exposes
other people but if you believe that the
vaccines are effective why are you
afraid if you believe they work which
they don't always work to 100% for sure
so vaccination is an individual choice
is to protect individuals not for a
room thank you Mr chairman and uh would
you mind sharing your uh educational
background sure from start to finish or
just more recently uh maybe professional
that leads you to use the term doctor
yes sure uh uh I'm a physician MD uh
went to uh University of
Vermont residency at Dartmouth
fellowship at Baylor practice at congr
hospital as a uh pathologist a medical
director for 27 years oh followup follow
up uh did you take any fellowships in
infectious disease no I did not thank
you saying no other
questions hey thank you
sir no one else has signed up uh to
speak on HB 357 so I am going to close
the public hearing on HB 357 and move on
to the public hearing on HB
358 uh we are awaiting uh the arrival is
he oh I'm sorry representative
kofel yeah you so quiet back there I
thank you chair recognizes
representative
kofalt thank you Mr chairman thank you
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is Jim kofalt please be
quiet in the back sorry interrupt uh
thank you uh for the record my name is
Jim kofalt I represent Hillsboro County
District 32 comprising the towns of
Wilton Temple and new
ipswitch house Bell 358 um is is aimed
at
correcting an unanticipated problem that
arose when we pass legislation several
years ago uh through this committee
actually um that was aimed at
simplifying the religious exemption
process for
parents um in 2022 uh we the the house
passed House Bill
1035 that went on to the Senate was
passed there and was signed into law by
the governor Prime sponsor of that
legislation was uh at the time
representative Tim Lang who most of you
know now as Senator Tim Lang
the bill analysis that is the short uh
blurb at the top of the uh of the draft
legislation uh stated very simply this
bill removes the requirement that a
parent request for a religious exemption
to immunizations required for School
attendance be notorized
that was the intent of the bill to
remove the requirement that it be
notorized so it was intended to simplify
the process for
parents um but unfortunately there was a
single word in that bill that um created
some controversy following its passage
and that bill that word was
form previously there was no standard
form the passage of a bill with the word
form in it uh prompted the Department of
Health and Human Services to create a
form um this raised several issues and
the the bill sponsor now Senator Lang uh
raised some serious concerns uh about
the the changes or the the
implementation of a form and some of the
questions uh that were on it so
um first and foremost the new
form asked and still asks parents to
disclose which vaccines their children
will not be receiving or haven't
received um Senator Lang raised the
concern that that information might be
used um you know to to bring some
accusations of neglect against parents
who who had chosen to forgo a
vaccination he also um asserted that you
know he believes that it it could
violate the right to live free from
government intrusion in private personal
information which is natural essential
and inherent uh which is now part of our
New Hampshire
Constitution so there was a an initial
version of the form and then later the
department changed it so the initial
version actually had uh three places
that they were asking parents to initial
um to acknowledge certain risks the risk
of Contracting a disease the risk of
transmitting a disease and the risk of
being excluded from the school or
daycare center that they attend uh the
form required parents or Guardians to
initial each of those warnings
individually um the department has since
revised the form to remove those first
two warnings and to remove the uh the
three places where parents were to
initial it um and simply have a
signature at the bottom of the form they
do still um
disclose that parents or Guardians uh
you know should be aware that their
children may be in the event of an of an
outbreak their children may be excluded
from attending the school or daycare
center uh that they normally attend if
they are not vaccinated um so I I do
believe that the changes that were made
to the Forum were a step in the right
direction um however since schools are
now arguing that parents must use that
specific form uh that was not the
original intent uh um the purpose of
this bill is quite
simple which is to clarify
unequivocally uh that the statute should
reflect the original intent of that bill
which was again to quote remove the
requirement that a parent request for
religious exemption to immunizations
required for School attendance be
notorized uh so uh that is the intent of
the bill that ends my testimony and I'll
be happy to take any questions any
questions wow
thank
you also signed up to speak is
Alon thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee um I was through the
record my name is Erica Leon I represent
Rockingham 13 which is the town of Derry
I was a member of this committee um when
the this bill uh the original bill was
passed I was also a member of jel car
when the form was adopted throughout the
entire process there was never any
expectation that this would be an exclus
that that the form in current use would
be an exclusive form when we approve the
form offered by the health by the
Department of Health and Human Services
in Jael car it was under the idea that
it was one potential form that as a
convenience a parent could sign but
never under the expectation that it was
the only way to um actually show that
you were using a religious exemption the
way that this entire process has been
implemented has been very contrary to
legislative intent um the intent is that
a parent simply says we have a religious
exemption we have a religious objection
to vaccination and that that is accepted
this bill and this language is required
in order to follow through on that
because having a religious test having
something where you need to put out
these specifics and these details um is
not helpful and it just builds upon the
skepticism because people feel that they
are being singled out for their religion
for their choices and as we all know the
issue of vaccination has become far too
contentious people should be looking at
the underlying data and science but
right now A lot of people are fueled by
emotions the more that we can take that
out of the equation and stop being
overly intrusive into people's lives the
better and I ask that you pass this
because the form that we approved in
Jael car was never intended to be used
as a sole exclusive form in order to
show give your religious exemption so I
ask that you fix this fix this by
passing this Bill thank you thank you
any
you also signed up to speak are Colleen
Smith and Dr Benjamin Shan from the
good
afternoon thank you again chairman
McDonald and members of the committee
for the record my name is Colleen Smith
I'm the cheer chief of the Bureau of
Infectious Disease Control within the
Department of Health and Human Services
and I'm a joined by Dr Benjamin Chan who
is our state epidemiologist and an
infectious disease physician we are here
to express concerns today on HB 358 that
is relative to use of the a religious
exemption form currently
RSA 141 c20c allows for medical and
religious exemptions to school and child
care immunization
requirements this change that this bill
would allow would be in lie of a signed
statement in lie of a form assigned
statement which could be simply an email
or handwritten note if this bill were to
pass the department has concerns that um
that this would take away a standardized
way for schools to collect this schools
and child carees to collect this
information this this benefits them in
having a defined process with clear
information collected so they can
clearly identify which which child is
seeking this exemption and then also
there is an optional section as was
mentioned in the in previous testimony
that to disclose which specific
immunizations were um are being Exempted
because not all parents exempt all from
all not all parents choose to exempt
their children from all immunizations
they may choose certain ones so this is
this is a way for a school or child care
care to clearly ident Iden ify which
child and which which immunizations
exemption is being sought this becomes
very important in the um event of a uh
vaccine pres preventable outbreak in a
school where children that do not have
um proof of immunization would be ex
required to be excluded to prevent
spread of that
illness um in recent years as was
mentioned there have been
barriers to parents um that have been
removed
such as the
notorized
that since this has been uh since since
this time there has been an increase in
religious exemptions current Department
data from the 2024 2025 school year
indicates that um 5781 students that's
3.3% of all students have claimed
exemptions religious exemptions from
immunization and this when you compare
this to the 20 21 2022 school year
4216 students had claimed that religious
exemption and that was 2% of all
students so just in that in that short
time um ease of ease of the requirement
taking away that notarization may have
had an impact in the increase in the
religious
exemptions we feel that the form is as
and there's copies that have been
distributed to you is is a very simple
form and it ALS it it serves the benefit
of the school administration in having a
standardized way of receiving that
information so again we we would like to
emphasize that we think keeping our
children with high vaccination rates is
important to the protection of not only
students within that that school and
child care but also our whole community
and we would be happy to answer any
questions that you may have thank you
representative Lucas and representative
palazov um in looking at the form and
thank you Mr chairman and thanks for
taking my question um I read that uh
please specify vaccines for which is
exemption applies
optional the information is voluntary
and if you choose not to provide the
requested information it will not impact
religious exemption is that current
that's current yes thank you
representative
palazov uh thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question so you you
mentioned how this uh standardized form
may help uh uh schools uh uh how it can
help your department and are there any
scenarios when Department have access uh
to detailed information in this form I I
see you provided uh overall numbers of
uh uh uh students who took uh this
exemptions so you uh you probably
receive that statistics from school but
uh does it matter for Department uh that
form is in its current
form so so the form doesn't this form it
would only be the serve the benefit in
the event of an outbreak because it
facilitates the school administration
from from helping them to document which
children
have claimed that religious exemption
and may need to be excluded from school
but the the department doesn't collect
this form on a regular basis it's simply
a tool to be used for schools and child
carees to help them collect this
information in a standardized
way um chair if I can also quickly add
that this this form is kept in by the
school it's the purpose of this form is
for the school to record and document
which students might have a religious
exemption this for form does not come to
the department we do not have
information to my knowledge at least at
the department level on each and every
child that has an exemption this this is
collected and stored at the school level
but we get aggregate reports um which I
think is what Colleen was talking about
in terms of the the exemption rates um
and the forms can also become important
if for example there's a you know a kid
with measles at school for example where
we have to go into the school and say
all right which which kids in this
classroom or which kids in this area um
are who are exposed to measles aren't
vaccinated and we try and connect them
with appropriate care but you know at
the end of the day you know a disease
like measles is highly infectious and so
there may need to be consideration for
exclusion if kids are not immunized to
stop an outbreak and that's where you
know working with the school that has
the form can come into play and be
important thank you anyone else
representative Weber thank you just two
quick ones if I may Mr chairman um so in
the event of an
outbreak um would you be excluding not
only the children who are unvaccinated
for religious exemption but all children
file um so again going back to so I I
think partly it's going to depend um so
thank you for that question it's it's a
it's a really good question and I think
partly it's going to depend on the
situation um but with something like
measles for example um there is a
requirement for documentation of
immunization otherwise there's a
consideration that that person be
excluded until we can get that
documentation so so the documentation
aspect of this actually is really
important because it impacts actions
that are taken at the school and the
family level so so if I may follow up on
that one so my question wasn't really
geared towards documentation it was all
children in the event of an outbreak of
say
measles all children who were
unvaccinated would be excluded until the
outbreak was over is that correct it
would not be solely on the basis of
somebody's religious beliefs or
exemption that's correct thank you um
and then I had another quick one but I
can't remember what it is so Let It Go
representative Woods uh thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question uh just in terms of complexity
of uh and inconvenience and you may not
be able to answer this but uh say a
child wants to go on a a a a day trip uh
they have to have a permission slip
uh does this compare to that or or can a
parent just send a note like the the um
Bill States just send in a piece of
paper or do they have to have a form or
do you know at this point I'm trying to
get some level of what parents are used
to So currently they they use the the
form that I provided to you this form if
this bill were enacted it would it would
strip that requirement away and they
could just write a handwritten note on a
comparative basis if a child wants to do
something else do they have to fill out
a standard form for a trip or whatever
or to the parent just and again you may
not be able to answer I mean in my
experience as a parent you know not not
speaking um necessarily through the
department there are forms that are you
know typically required for you know
trips and I think that that's that's the
intent of this form is to have something
that is standardized that schools can
use um I I believe there's somebody
speaking after us from the schools who's
going to talk about you know use of
these forms in the school system and so
they may be more appropriate to answer
your question but I think the the intent
I mean if you look at the form the form
will requires two things identifying who
the child is and a signature um and so
already this form is essentially
assigned assigned uh you know a parent
assigning that a child has a religious
exemption for a vaccine the purpose of
the form is to have a standardized way
of recordkeeping that um my
understanding is most schools across the
state have chosen to adopt because it's
useful and beneficial for their
administrative internal
processes representative Weber my mind
taken its leave came back uh I just
wanted to verify you spoke of the
aggregate the forms being kept at the
school level and only aggregated data
sent to the Department of Health so um
am I correct in assuming that the
aggregated data has no um identifying
information on specific children just
the aggregate numbers from the
school that is that is correct thank you
schools submit um just their aggregate
data to us thank
you anyone
you also signed up to speak is Pam
denapoli from The New Hampshire School
nurses
thank you um Pam denapoli still
registered nurse um I
um I'm actually a school nurse in the
Manchester School District so um we
surveyed um our members on this bill and
really feel it's unnecessary because we
use the form we love the form because if
you think about the role of the school
nurse we have anywhere from 500 to 1,000
children in our schools and we have to
keep records on all those children so if
we had no standardized way of keeping
that records it makes our job very um
difficult because it's inefficient often
duplicative our kids especially in
Manchester they may switch schools two
or three times in a school year and to
try to keep track if somebody's coming
into our district what form did they use
how do how do we know there's a
religious exemption so um we really feel
like this is this is non isue because we
use the form the um most of the forms
that I get back where it has the little
check marks about what your um what
you're uh exempting from isn't even
filled out it's usually the child's name
the parent signature and we C we just
document in our computer system
religious exemption so at the point
where there may be a need to exclude
children we would go back to those forms
so we would contact the parents and say
exactly is your child IMU immunized
against measles so we like it when it's
filled out but it's not necessarily
filled out because it's optional um
parents are used to forms what we
usually do is that the beginning of the
year they get a packet of forms so they
get the religious exemption form they
get a form if their child's going to get
medication in school they get a form if
their child's going to go on a on a
field trip if they need any special
accommodations so they get a packet of
forms they sign them they come back to
the administration and they go go to the
nurse if it's a nurse form they go to
the guidance if it's a guidance form so
um we're really used to forms and um
it's a consistent process that we're
used to if if children move across
District we have the form we know what
to look for we're not looking for a
handwritten note somewhere in their
file so um this we we just feel like we
need we like the form we need the form
if the school chooses not to use the
form that's up to them it's not required
but DHHS sends it to the to the
administration they distribute it to us
we distribute it to the parents we get
it back and it's it's a it's a seamless
process and I think in terms of the
question about would you exclude a a
student if they didn't have immunization
on file right now you have 30 days you
have 30 days to um if you're if you
don't have an immunization record on
file or a religious exemption you're
automatically excluded from the school
so we do a lot of tracing back to to
children without the file thank you
representative kessle ring thank you Mr
chair just a quick question in your
experience you said Manchester correct
um does this form where does it go and
who has access to it if it's turned in
it goes to the school nurse and that's
that's and then we have all their
medical records are usually well they're
in a computer system and that we have
access to and then they're locked in a
file in case this computer system goes
down okay thank you
anyone
Condon please put your microphone
on thank
you thank you my name is Laura Condon
I'm from Bedford New Hampshire and I'm
here um to testify in support of this
bill I think this is uh an important
clarification for this I remember when
the bill was changed the law was changed
to remove the notary requirement and I
did have parents come to me and I do
have many people come to me across the
state wanting to know um do they need a
form not need a form and I said you know
you really just need a statement you can
create a form and I I actually created a
form for them and I shared that with a
lot of people I I thought it was a great
form as all the information that um a
school nurse or a daycare provider would
would need whether the child has um a
religious exemption or not and I think
there are some important points that
were mentioned here in this hearing one
is that when that bill was changed DHHS
came out and with a form and they
changed had to change it three different
times and they had to change it because
it had very aggressive language in there
it was aggressive language with
unauthorized request ests requirements
about putting in your vaccination
history and I think sorry he's left the
room but I think that speaks to
representative McLean's concerned that
he's raised time and time again um
public trust and when DHHS becomes
unnecessarily aggressive with requests
for information that is neither required
nor authorized in State Statute they
undermine public trust so um I'm glad
the form has improved and I hope we'll
make further improvements and when
parents the form that provided her
parents had nothing on there about
vaccinations but I have many parents
come to me and said well you know my
child got this vaccine That vaccine do I
need to list them and I've always
advised parents that it's up to them I
said you can simply assert your
religious um e exemption and leave it at
that or if you're so inclined you can
share with the school nurse what
vaccines your child has already gotten
that that's up to you so you can
voluntarily share that information I
never encourage somebody to withhold it
but I have made them aware in the event
of an outbreak if your child say has had
the masel shot at that point so your
child's not excluded you'd want to
provide that record so your child would
not be excluded at that point in time I
do know that DHHS testify that the
religious exemption rate is now up to
you know very small
3.3% but I also note that that has had
no negative impact whatsoever that
increase in religious
exemption and I note that the the nurse
who just test testified said that she
she docu these forms come in in various
forms these exemptions and she documents
them in her computer system so there is
a system that Aggregates this data that
makes it all uniform at that point so at
any point in time the school nurse does
know who's has an exemption and and who
who does not so that information is
there but the question was asked who has
access to that and she did testify that
just stays with the school does stay
with school but we also heard Dr and
testify that in the event of an outbreak
that they go into the school and they
look at those records so those are not
private from DHHS staff as we heard from
Dr Chan's testimony happy to take any
questions please pass this bill any
you also signed up to speak is Aubrey
Friedman
Mr chairman committee members Aubrey
Friedman I speaking support of this bill
I'll I'll make it brief um this to me is
a data sharing issue and in our own so I
originally thought that it was the dhss
that was keeping the uh maybe keeping
tabs on all this stuff they say it's at
the school level well my school district
is New Found and we had a big hacking
late it was November of 2023 and they
are still at this date still recovering
so as was mentioned they enter it into
the computer anytime you enter things in
the computer you don't know what's going
to happen with that information are they
going to share it with other agencies or
third parties or whatever there's been a
lot of I think abuse on that in that
area and even if they did everything
perfectly okay they're still hacking and
so why do they need all you need is the
name of the child and the parents
signing it that they they uh they want
to take advantage of the religious
exemption and that's it so they don't
need any more information it's best to
give less information these days for
everybody especially your children so I
don't think uh we need that form and a
note from the parents should good enough
and if there really is like a measles
outbreak I would think the school would
just be uh send out a grand announcement
to all the families if your child has
not been vaccinated for measles keep
your kids at home so there's no need for
any big surveillance or whatever you
just tell those parents we advise you to
keep your kids at home we have a measel
outbreak at school so um that's why
those are the reasons I support this
Bill thank you any questions
see done thank you thank
you okay that is that gentleman was the
last to sign up to testify does anyone
else wish to testify before I close the
hearing on HB
358 seeing no one I am closing this
public hearing uh we will reconvene in
about five minutes to uh hear HB 701 FN
recess
e
okay welcome back to the house committee
on Health and Human Services and elderly
affairs we have our last hearing of the
day which is HB 701 FN and to introduce
this before the committee I will
recognize representative Lisa merer from
Grown yes hello everyone for the third
time this
[Laughter]
week thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is Lisa
merer representing Hillsboro District 44
the towns of gtown and where I am here
today to introduce HB 701
- FN Rel relative to a health care
patient's right to try certain emergency
Health Care treatment options simply put
the goal of this bill is to make New
Hampshire the best jurisdiction in the
country for clinical trials and quote
right to try for people with
lifethreatening
illnesses with the Advent of gene
therapy the world is witnessing a rise
in Innovative treatments for
life-threatening and rare diseases new
sure has a unique opportunity in this
area not only to help countless people
in need but to pursue a rare Economic
Opportunity Boston's biotech Hub where a
large share of this Innovation is
happening is 40 minutes from New
Hampshire if we establish ourselves as
the most friendly and pioneering
jurisdiction in in America for
experimental treatments for people with
terminal illnesses we have a truly
unique opportunity to easily draw
Innovation and business into the state
I'd like to highlight five areas where
this bill is different from our current
right to try law first is Cutting Edge
limitation on civil liability our
current right to try law RSA 126 DZ
already limits regulatory enforcement
actions against providers who give
experimental treatments to consenting
terminally ill patients
hp71 will go further allowing terminally
ill patients to consent to a strong
limitation on civil liability that will
help them access experimental treatments
this will make New Hampshire competitive
with Montana which is now the leading
right to try jurisdiction in the country
and is unique in its civil liability
limitations the committee will receive
extensive written testimony from people
who sought who were PR who were prepared
to pay for right to try treatments for
their own dying loved ones the problem
is that even in so-called right to
States the threat of civil liability
more than regulatory enforcement almost
completely deters manufacturers and
providers from actually selling or
granting experimental treatments to
dying patients second remote
pre-screening for treatment HB 71 would
make New Hampshire the first state to
recognize a state law right for
providers physically present in New
Hampshire to conduct a remote
pre-screening for experimental treatment
when a patient is ding D in this would
mitigate one of the largest logistical
obstacles that Dy in patients around the
country face in trying to access
treatments and could thereby attract
significant business to New Hampshire
from Boston and elsewhere although the
bill says quote tella Health
pre-screening it's important to
emphasize that a pre-screening interview
is not the kind of quote Healthcare we
usually think of when we hear the word
telea Health a pre-screening is simply
an initial meeting to determine whether
a patient can apply to receive treatment
many dying patients who want to access
experimental treatment spend the last
months of their lives physically flying
around the country primarily just to be
rejected in various in-person
pre-screening appointments we should do
everything possible under state law to
make sure that at least these initial
pre-screening appointments can happen in
person third remote signing of consent
forms this change is similar to the one
just described but in this case the
problem is that there are many cases of
dying patients flying from one state to
another simply to sign a consent form in
the physical presence of a health care
provider even when they are not going to
receive treatment on that trip fourth a
construction provision to help reassure
providers and patients that may
encounter additional unforeseen
regulatory illegal situations we'll also
add a broad construction provision state
stating that our purpose in passing this
law is to incentivize providers and
manufacturers to treat dying patients
who want treatment as well as to quote
make New Hampshire a jurisdiction that
attracts and fosters clinical trials and
the development of drugs biologics and
devices intended to treat
life-threatening conditions the law
should be always be interpreted
consistently with this purpose Fifth and
last a right to injunction to an
injunction finally the most important
part of this bill and the piece that
holds it all together is the right of a
provider or patient to seek injunctive
relief against a state regulatory or law
enforcement Authority that is
obstructing their treatment under our
current law providers need to sit by
wait to see if a State Licensing
Authority or agency will come after them
and then invoke our current law 106 DZ
as an affirmative defense but the
reality is this does not provide any
cautious healthc care provider with the
incentive they need to provide treatment
instead New Hampshire can offer
providers from Boston who come up and
set up shop in New Hampshire a unique
degree of predictability and stability
by Leading the country in this area New
Hampshire can both save numerous lives
lives like Lucas Toro a famous young
muscular distrophy patient who is
undergoing successful gene therapy in
Boston and attract business and
Innovation to New Hampshire on a last
and personal
note after walking with um with my dad
uh through his terminal diagnosis
sorry with no potential life-saving
options presented to or available to him
I strongly support protecting the rights
of patients with terminal
diagnosis to access potential
life-saving or life extending
treatments I urge this committee to
stand with
patience their famili and the phys
Physicians who are trying to help extend
their lives by ensuring that patient
compassionate ensuring that
compassionate access to emergency
treatments remains a protected right
thank you thank you any any
representative
Weber thank you and I'll let you take a
breath I'm so sorry about your dad and
it's a tough Journey y um and I also
honor the sentiment behind this so I'm
going to turn to some really technical
questions about the drafting answer them
there are there is someone behind me who
can okay so I'll just ask the question
if you want to pass go ahead um so the
questions I have are on the bottom of
page I guess it's page one uh
where um lines 27 to
29 and it talks
about uh the protections for the
providers and um it says that they're
they're only protected if they haven't
engaged in willful misconduct so that's
one legal standard um is it okay to let
them off the hook if they have been
negligent which would not be covered if
this statute was passed like this or is
that some drafting that we need to work
on I guess I'll defer that um there's a
a lawyer behind me that will okay um and
then I just wanted to note also I my
question uh on the next page which is
headed page
two uh the draft removes almost
everything
that is of protective language on lines
2 through
7 um and just refers to paragraph
two I think there would you agree with
that there might be a
concern arising out of the removal of
protections on page
two um when this is supposed to provide
more
protections I I'm I don't have the
numbers that you have on yours so the
the is it section one it's it says uh
it's headed private cause of action okay
y um and if you if you note it's
it as redrafted by the bill
yep it would say nothing in this chapter
shall be construed to create a private
cause of
action against any person or entity
except as specified in paragraph 2 and
it sounds like it's removing some
protections as opposed to adding them
yeah because the that slowed down the
process um and if did you did you all
hopefully receive some of the
testimonies from from a specific I'm I'm
just talking about specific wording and
and whether I'm trying to explore
whether this language and it's tough
it's tough for me because it's double
negatives um I'm just trying to explore
whether the language as written does
exactly what you want it to do okay so
if there are other people behind you who
can help me with that that will be
helpful I'm sure there
are yes anyone else have any questions
representative
elberger thank you Mr chair and I'm
trying to make sure that I'm not dealing
with a keen grasp of the obvious but
this you're only referring here to
legitimate clinical trials you're not
talking about somebody like me saying if
you go walk in the woods and touch oak
trees you're going to be
better I mean we're we're only talking
about legitimate medical trials in this
for for terminal illnesses yes yes okay
thank
you other
questions representative woods and then
delas thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question uh I I guess I
need a little bit of clarification again
someone else may be able to answer it uh
um the the role of just uh prescribing
an off label medication is one entity
another entity is being prescribing a
medication as part of a trial if it's
part of a trial then there the irbs get
involved uh and that's another whole
layer and I don't see that addressed
here so if someone either yourself or
someone else could comp uh clarify
whether we're talking about uh you know
just off label which most of us as
Physicians do it regularly versus a a
true trial which was um referred to just
now MH I I think the IRB if it's a trial
the irbs are going to get involved
okay thank
you representative
damus thank you Mr chairman um is does
this have any verbiage or does it how
does it mesh with the um right to uh
right to try act that was um enacted in
2018 yes um I I actually just was
looking up that today and gosh I don't
remember I'd have to look because that
was a a president Trump yes yes yeah he
signed that in 17 yeah and I don't I
don't recall what where it actually went
after that so whether because it there
was also an executive order involved in
that so I don't know if that was
repealed afterwards or um it was hard to
tell when I was looking it up what
actually happened to to it so I I
believe it's actually still
in I think it's law yeah and I and it's
and they're they're saying like it's a
right to try 2.0 yeah so and many states
have right to try laws I mean we do
right now too this makes us Cutting Edge
in the country of going Beyond um and
and and as mentioned in my testimony of
making us a hub you know know for th
this accessibility to treatment that
will save lives so it goes beyond what's
out there already y anyone
you also signed up to speak is attorney
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee Ian huitt attorney for
Cornerstone appearing in strong support
of Representative maser's House Bill
sorry pronouncing your name by the way
oh you did a pretty good job actually
I've heard much worse mispronunciations
around here and we are New Hampshire's
only full-time Christian advocacy
organization we represent over 100
churches around the state and I would
love to answer any technical legal
questions including wording questions
about how this bill would work but in my
testimony I thought I would talk a bit
about why we support this bill today is
actually Ash wedes day on which uh many
Christians of different denominations
around the world receive ashes on their
foreheads and they do that often as a
way of reme remembering the curse of the
fall in which Christians believe
sickness and death came into the world
and Christians believe that we have a
duty to treat to heal to care for the
sick in part because we believe we are
in a state of war with the fall the
beginning of the ninth chapter of John
talks about Jesus heals a man who was
born blind and he says that his
followers must do the same he says we
must work the works of him who sent us
now unfortunately in legal regimes
around the country right now the
government typically does not value
healing as much as it values the
predictability of regul a even if that
regulation results in death so I want to
draw your attention to two of written
testimonies that you already have and
I'm going to pass around copies of them
as well but one of them is a testimony
from Dr Bess Stillman who is a powerful
writer and Advocate and new mom whose
husband Jake died in August of cancer
and there were revolutionary Medical
Treatments in existence that may have
been able to heal Jake and best Stillman
and Jake traveled around the country
seeking these treatments They begged for
access to them they offered to pay for
everything out of pocket they wanted to
wave civil liability but their
experience was even under state standard
state right to try laws like ours and
the federal right to try law that Health
Care Providers were much more scared of
the possibility of civil liability
through harming Jake than they were
scared of Jake dying
I will also give you written testimony
from a group of six sets of parents with
of children with terminal genetic
illnesses and therapies now in
development like the one you heard about
from representative merer Lucas Toro is
an inspiring successful gene therapy
case in Massachusetts therapies now
being developed could potentially treat
many of these genetic illnesses but none
of these six children will survive to
adulthood unless they are allowed to
access re evolutionary treatments and
these parents have all spoken about and
you will read in their testimony about
how right to try laws like ours are well
intentioned and sound nice on paper but
the reality is that stop wrapping up
please providers are too Paralyzed by
the threat of civil liability and the
threat of regulatory interference to
administer treatments that are needed to
save these people's lives so we hope you
will stand with those who cannot speak
for themselves and join us in supporting
representative Meers House Bill 701 I'd
love to take any legal or technical
questions about how this bill would work
thank you representative
Weber thank you and thank you for
offering to take the question um I'm
also turning you to uh the first page of
the bill language um which isn't
numbered but um which has online 27 to
29 the manufacturer pharmacist facility
provider or other person has not engaged
in willful conduct why did you choose
willful conduct and exclude negligent
conduct well almost all state right to
try laws still allow uh cause of action
in the case of negligence uh our current
right to try law for example says that
you're not subject to civil liability so
long so long as you've exercised
reasonable care and the reality is and
you can see this from all these patients
who best Stillman likes to say we tried
right to try you go into any of these
states that have these laws you offer to
pay and the doctors are still too
Paralyzed by fear of civil liability to
administer treatments that are available
and you can imagine the attorneys at
these medical facilities look at a law
like ours and say it says we're going to
be potentially subject to a lawsuit if
we don't exercise reasonable care and
that sounds an awful lot like the
ordinary standard for civil liability
for a medical provider so the entire
impetus behind what all of these patient
in these written testimonies are saying
is they really they're going to die
anyway they just want greater ability to
wave civil liability so that doctors
will have the incentives in place to
offer treatment and I I just can't I
struggle to imagine how frustrating it
would be for these parents of these
young children with genetic illnesses to
be told we can't treat you because we're
afraid of the Civil liability from
injuring your child when the parents
know their children are not going to
live to be adults without treatment and
they need to be able to wave the Civil
liability to a great extent to make it
available so could I follow up and I
understand the emotional content of what
you're dealing with I can't imagine the
pain of having to deal with a situation
like this but I don't think you actually
answered my question which is um I
didn't talk about the reasonable
reasonable Care standard what I asked
was um you have have not you you you
saying here uh and I'm trying to remove
all the double negatives because it does
get very confusing um it sounds to me
reading lines 27 to 29 that if you
engaged in actual willful
misconduct the patient has a right of
action yes that's correct and the
question I have is so you Escape
liability if you have merely been
negligent towards your critically ill
patient yes that's correct the reason
for that is that when you have a statute
that says you are going to be liable in
the case of negligence which is simply
effectively an ordinary medical
malpractice standard that doesn't
provide enough incentive to encourage
providers to administer treatments that
people desperately want and that they
otherwise would would like to be able to
provide but they're deterred by civil
liability so when we're making the
calculation in this language that when
someone is dying anyway and goes through
informed consent and the other checks
that are in here there are certain
requirements like informed consent
physician approval um certification that
there's no alternative FDA approved
treatments but when someone goes through
those checks they want to be able to
greatly wave civil liability because if
they can't wave civil liability around
negligence the reality is well it sounds
sounds nice theoretically to say we're
going to leave negligence liability in
place that completely deters all of
these facilities and doctors around the
country from administering treatments
that in fact exists That Dying people
would like to
access and can I have one one more on
the construction of the language there
um It also says willful condu conduct
willful
misconduct shall include any conduct
intended to hasten the death of the
patient
um in do you think that including that
specific
language and I absolutely agree we
patients but does the inclusion of that
language again get us back into the
tension
between has what I have administered
been truly experimental and helpful or
oh gosh it hastened the death of the
patient and therefore we're back to
being concerned
about an outcome that may not have been
intended or anticipated but may be very
bad or may be
hastening well in my experience when I'm
advising clients in a litigation context
you know either in my current role where
I I do constitutional litigation or
related State statory litigation or in
my my previous work doing civil
litigation if there is a requirement of
willful intent and some sort of
malicious intent I'm much more
comfortable telling clients they can
proceed with uh important but
potentially risking risky conduct and
that is because when you have a
statutory element like willful
misconduct willfully hastening the death
of the patient in order to get civil
liability there would need to be
significant evidence that the healthc
care provider actually had that mental
state it's not enough to just show that
the conduct didn't meet a reasonable
standard of care you need to show that
it was willfully bad and so that uh
reaches a compromise by not entirely
waving civil liability we're not saying
as long as you go through steps a a
through C civil liability is 100% gone
but we need to give patients like these
ability to significantly wave civil
liability through informed consent to
access and pay for the treatments that
they want and New Hampshire uh is in is
in a especially uniquely uh wonderful
position to enact reforms like this
because of our proximity to a biotech
Hub thank you thank you for bearing with
thank you other
questions representative delus thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um what comes to mind is the uh
exemption for manufacturers of vaccines
not to go back to vaccines but those
manufacturers and entities are are not
liable for any damage Dage done could
language from I don't even know what the
language is I'd have to look it up but
could something like that be fit fitted
into this so that the the people
administering the
experimental uh treatments would
be
left not liable
for possibly having a uh an out come
that was certainly maybe even opposite
of what the treatment was meant to be
thank you representative damus that's a
helpful analogy we have the government
has statutory blanket exemption on
liability for vaccine manufacturers
because it made the Judgment call that
promoting vaccines is so important we
want to create a special incentive
structure that promotes vaccination now
this is different in that that is a
blanket waiver of liability zero
liability uh this does not uh this goes
to representative Weber's question this
is more moderate than that it's not a
blanket waiver of liability it leaves
some liability in place um so this is
kind of a middle ground between current
standard right to tral laws which sound
nice until you realize that the
negligence liability that isn't waved is
basically just ordinary medical
liability which doesn't really
incentivize providers to administer
these treatments it's a middle ground
between that and something like blanket
exemption of liability um for
vaccination now if someone goes through
informed consent if they're dying anyway
way you know I think certainly if it was
my relative my child if it was me uh I'd
be I'd be happy with if I carefully
chose the provider with a blanket waiver
on liability if I went through informed
consent and went through steps a through
C but I think D is retained in here in
the spirit of compromise of showing that
this isn't a total waiver on liability
there is some left in place so it's not
it's not absolutely anything goes but
it's further than anyone else is going
so that we can draw these patients and
providers to New
Hampshire thank you thank you for your
question other questions repres of
kesing so is there any other states
sorry thank you Mr chair sorry the um
the provisions of this is there any
other state that has anything like this
that you would point to yes Montana is
very similar this would put us a a bit
beyond where Montana is but Montana is
currently the leading state in the
country for ride to try and clinical
trials in that they greatly ctail civil
liability which ordinary standard state
right to trial do not curtail regulatory
enforcement which sounds good but then
the reality is you go to these providers
and they say I'm absolutely paralyzed
and terrified of civil liability I can't
treat you you'll just have to die uh
Montana does limit civil liability but
we're very different from Montana and
that there is no biotechnology Hub in
Montana or 40 minutes from Montana so
there's every reason to think New
Hampshire could play a revolutionary
role more than any of the other 49
states if we took the lead in this area
and Drew some of these innovators to
just set up shop 40 minutes away
patients like the children and families
in the written testimony would come to
New Hampshire and this bill could save
their
lives thank you anyone
else representative
lontine thank you Mr chair and thanks
for taking my question thank you and at
the risk of embarrassing myself for a
third time by not reading this really
correctly today um but but somewhere in
the statute when a patient wants this
treatment and their consent do they not
also sign something that we accept this
experimental
and we're not going to sue the doctor
yes thank you for your excellent
question that is on um page one and that
is on lines 24 through 26 there is a
requirement of written informed con ENT
um and that informed consent requires a
certain mental capacity so it's not
signature representative Weber and as a
followup to representative laman's
question um the informed consent
provision is very helpful but I think
that what she was asking about is why
would the patient not also I mean
obviously if this is if this is PED it
gets around the necessity but wouldn't a
physician also ask a patient for a
waiver of liability rather than just
informed
consent well of course uh and this would
Empower them to wave liability um so you
take for example actually Dr Stillman
talks about in her written testimony
this in very explicit detail she was she
said write up whatever you want I'll
sign any waiver of anything you want I
just she had she an ER doctor she'
researched this treatment she said this
may save my husband's life I don't care
about the risks he's about to die in a
matter of months please administer the
treatment I will wave liability and the
lawyers for the doctor advised him this
waiver of liability will not be
effective so um we need statutory
clarification to say that you are
allowed through informed consent to wave
liability to to create a revolutionary
legal regime that will attract these
kinds of treatments to the
state repres Castle
thank you Mr chair just a follow-up
question so legally would this be
required as one document to be signed or
would multiple Physicians dealing with
that patient have to sign similar forms
for each of these yes thank you for your
question there are multiple and this is
fairly common among ride to tr laws but
we incorporated this into this bill text
there are multiple Physicians that are
involved in this process and the the key
Provisions to look at here are on the
first page uh 19 through about 23 so you
need physician certific a of
life-threatening disease and then you
need physician certification of no
alternative FDA approved treatments and
then only then would you qualify for the
informed
consent representative
lontine thank you Mr chair but about
that con informed
consent um I'm a little
surprised that you would allow
someone who lacks a mental capacity to
have someone else give this
consent oh can you elaborate on that
well if you look for example at um the
testimony which you all have and all
distribute from the six sets of parents
uh one of whom is the president of
something called the lcmd Research
Foundation that's a lethal genetic
illness that may very soon be treatable
um similar genetic illnesses are being
treated and the other parents all have
genetic illnesses these these children
are very young so they're certainly
going to die unless they receive some
revolutionary treatment when they're
children and they don't have the
capacity to make these sorts of informed
decisions on their own so all of these
parents want to air on the side of let's
administer the treatment even though
that that means we're giving consent on
their behalf um because they're
certainly not going to be in a position
to make this decision as adults if
they're not treated as
children H your microphone's not on it
wasn't the question about the minor but
for
someone or or lack the mental
capacity
um well that someone with that type of
language is I'm I'm sorry representative
someone with an intellectual disability
something like that would not have the
that be able to give
consent yes um so the language here in
under informed consent says if the
patient is a minor or lacks the mental
capacity to provide informed consent a
parent or legal guardian has given
written informed consent on the
patient's behalf so yes that would
include people who are non-ch but
similarly don't have the legal capacity
to make that decision that is pretty
standard language in um that's one of
the less revolutionary things about this
bill that's in most right to try laws
and the intent there is basically you
may have an illness uh that greatly
deprives someone of the ability to make
an informed decision over the you know
the course of their dying and a relative
a legal guardian may want the capacity
to try to save that person's life
representative
Lucas thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question um just um and I I
I'm not familiar with the appropriate
legal terms but if someone has
previously indicated they didn't want
Extraordinary Measures to keep them
alive um would
this uh Clause once they become mentally
unable because of their illness to make
this kind of decision
but we know there preferences from
before would this bill allow
um close relative spouse child to then
override their previous preferences and
make the request for the medication I
think that's unlikely representative but
I don't think it would hurt the intent
of Bill whatsoever if there was an
explicit clarification to that effect
thank you thank you anyone else
seeing no one else oh I'm sorry
representative marel yes thank you uh
thank you thank you for taking my
question sir
um uh I'm thinking about health care
proxies in this particular situation
what do you foresee the impact of a
health care proxy for somebody
being and you were talking about legal
Guardians is that correct yes but I'm
also thinking so when I as I read your
bill I'm thinking about somebody for
example with Alzheimer's or some other
demen or some other impairment for
cognitive re sound cognitive reasoning
can you tell me what you think that the
health care the effect of a health care
proxy is is that going to be valid in
this situation if they have legal legal
guardianship of the person
representative than under the bill as
written now then they would be able to
provide written informed consent okay
okay follow-up question sir followup
thank you what if the healthc care proxy
doesn't necessarily include a re a
guardianship in our practice for example
example as an attorney we generally
design U paperwork for for Elder elder
care where we have healthc care proxies
and we have a variety of other things in
addition to wills and so forth and um so
the if I understand the intent of this
statute legislation is that it's going
to require somebody become a legal
guardian in addition to be giving a
healthcare proxy yes that's correct if I
can confidently say if someone had some
other kind of healthcare decision-making
Authority that did not rise to the level
of legal guardianship I can't imagine
any Court Reading into this explicit
requirement of legal guardianship that
you know any other Healthcare making
decision- making Authority is sufficient
okay thank you thank you anyone
else see oh representative
chairman this is a a very complicated
question from my point of view my
concerned if there's anything in this
legislation that would allow for
physician assisted
suicide that was I'm sorry
representative were you I didn't mean to
interrupt you
that's that that's a kind of a question
uh particularly
under uh
24 line
C the patient has given a written and
formed consent for the use of drug
biologic or so and
so it seems to give
permission uh for
suicide yes thank you for your question
representative I'm glad you brought that
up some stakeholders involved in
crafting this bill text wanted to ensure
that the bill did not speak one way or
the other to physician assisted suicide
that it did not prohibit physician
assisted suicide but also every all the
sponsors or many of the sponsors wanted
to make sure it did not provide any
further authorization to physician
assisted suicide and that is in fact why
20 lines 28 through 29 on page one say
willful misconduct shall include any
conduct intended to hasten the death of
a patient now to tie this Cinder
representative Weber's question neither
does this does do these two lines
prohibit uh intentionally hastening the
death of the patient in any new way
because it is a double negative so it is
saying liability is not waved under
these circumstances so it's it
explicitly does not wave liability if
there is any conduct intended to hasten
the death of the patient but neither
would it create any new liability uh in
that situation that doesn't exist now
representative Weber because of the uh
double negative of that overall
provision thank you thank you anyone
else seeing no one else thank you thank
lewicki thank you Mr chairman thank you
members of the committee you may
remember I was here a year ago and told
you that in New Hampshire not only um
unlike other places not only can dead
people vote they can uh speak before a
legislative committee um a year ago I
was probably a little bit closer to
death than I am now and this is a result
of actually doing right to try things on
my own uh my history four years ago
approximately this time of year I was
told that I had a treatable condition
when they say treatable that means
incurable um I've been living with this
for four years now I have tried numerous
things that have uh you know most of the
chicken soup basically things that are
going to do very little harm and can
actually have a potential Cur Curative
effect um and within the past year I've
done two things I was one of these
people flying around the country um did
one thing in Texas in uh at the end of
April last year and that was in my mind
um minimally effective uh then a few
months ago I went to Florida and had a
treatment which used agents that have
basically passed I don't know whether
they're completely into the public
domain but um you know well-known agents
in a different manner than usually given
and I'm currently seeing very positive
effects from that and one of the points
um now this is somewhat different from
hb300 last year but it's all going in
the same direction which is basically if
we have people who are fully informed
then why should they not be able to try
something that is potentially Curative
or might extend their lives and um as
the people before me have spoken um this
we have an establishment the legal
medical establishment and I don't say
Healthcare I used to have health care
but that was before I got this condition
um so
um The Establishment says if you do the
conventional thing then you're home free
if you do something unconventional and
it goes wrong then there's liability and
those concerns uh prevent treatment I
have doctors here in New Hampshire who
are very interested in what I did in my
treatment in Florida and who very
possibly would be willing to do it here
if things work out now I am a clinical
trial of one uh there's no drug company
that is going to promote the agents and
the treatment that I have received
because that treatment is never going to
make a drug company a billion dollars um
it um and so I cannot be a CL in a
clinical trial there is no clinical
trial to do the thing that I've done and
there won't be because of the lack of
financial incentive on the other hand
the incentives legal and U so forth are
to quite the opposite um and so what we
um being able to do these things is
really has to be outside okay and the
other thing that I'd like to point out
is that what we get from this not only
is perh perhaps people's lives being
saved or whatever we get data points in
the past year I've produced two data
points one of which was minimally
effective the other which appears to be
working um I'm quite willing to take you
know questions on the nuts and bolts of
this afterward I don't think I should
get into that here so there my story
thank you any
you Al
also signed up to speak is I believe
Hines I have your last name correct it's
Haynes thank you H I'm
sorry look like there was a DOT above
the second letter ma'am can you spell
s thank you chairman McDonald and thank
you members of the committee for
allowing me to speak my name is Holly
Haynes I'm a member of of the New
Hampshire Association for justice I'm a
resident of wear and I'm also a medical
malpractice attorney in Manchester New
Hampshire and I represent patients who
are harmed by NE negligent medical care
including care involving the negligent
use of drugs biologic products and
devices I also personally currently have
a family member who is engaged in a
clinical trial in the Boston area she
has a terminal illness and there are no
other treatments and she is um so I have
a personal interest in this I think this
bill is very well intentioned and I
certainly am in favor of clinical trials
I think they Foster advances in medicine
that are very good for patients but for
them to proceed they have to be highly
regulated they have to be performed
reasonably and they have to be performed
responsibly um this bill does not Foster
that or encourage that and that's the
reason that I'm here in opposition to
the language as Dr Ed I do think
amendments could be made that could make
this palatable to everyone and make it
consistent with federal law the first
reason for opposition to this is the
major change in it as members of this
committee know the New Hampshire
Association for justice is opposed to
any bill that encourages immunity from
liability one of the reasons that no
other state in the nation has this type
of blanket immunity or stay out of court
freedom is because it's prohibited by
federal law I have the Federal
Regulation which I tried to submit with
my testimony but I wasn't allowed to
submit to um require to attachments at
the same time and
CFR 21 CFR part
5020 regarding human subjects in
clinical trial require that no informed
consent whether oral or written may
include any exculpatory language through
which the subject or the representative
is made to wave or appear to wave any
the subject's legal rights or releases
or appears to release the investigator
the sponsor the institution or the
agents from any type of liability or
negligence that's codified in federal
law so the immunity Provisions are
already in violation of that and they
would be preempted by the Federal
Regulation so immunity itself is not a
good thing one of our responsibilities
as Society members is to act reasonably
we act reasonably and medical providers
need to act reasonably as well I think
that's one of the concerns that
representative Weber raised um you can't
be immune from unreasonable conduct
there are many cases I don't think any
medical provider in the state of New
Hampshire I don't think any
pharmaceutical please start wrapping up
manufacturer intends or would engage in
willful misconduct to harm a patient but
there are ways in a clinical trial that
it could be done unreasonably if for
example you were trying to get people
into the trial and get them into
treatment quickly a physician may not
look at a patient's entire medical
history
um I'm going to move on quickly if
you'll indulge me your time's pretty
much up but maybe the other piece of
language that I think needs to be
amended is this bill expands liability
sub U I'm sorry not liability but the
scope of the statute the right to try
statute significantly by extending it to
um illnesses as Oppo it's not terminal
illnesses anymore it extends it to
life-threatening diseases which is a
slippery slope of anything it could be
heart disease it could be diabetes it
could be dementia it could be
Alzheimer's or many other things we will
look at your online testimony if you
have anything else you want us to have
please feel free to email the committee
thank you chairman but in the meantime
we do have questions so representative
Weber thank
fine just didn't want to forget that
thank you um would you be willing to
provide us with language that you think
might both get us farther forward in
allowing patients to try things that
might be
helpful under appropriate circumstances
and that would not violate the federal
law is that something you could send it
send to us for to to work on I'm happy
to representative Weber and I think the
two easy amendments would be just
eliminating the immunity provisions and
switching all references to um
life-threatening illness to terminal
illness which is already defined in the
right to try statute thank you
representative Castle R thank you Mr
chair thank you for my question I'm
looking on line six it says ineligible
um on page one for or not selected uh to
participate in a clinical trial so does
that provision there change um the
federal let's say standing for clinical
trial since they're not really being
enrolled in a clinical trial just a
question on
that um that line if you read the entire
portion it's regarding pre-screening to
determine whether or not the person is
eligible or ineligible for the trial so
uh under the federal provision is there
a screening process that they would have
to qualify for that trial seeing is that
I'm just asking in reference to both I
believe that all clinical trials have
pre-screening and I can tell you from
personal experience with my mother's
clinical trial I'm a co-participant in
it and they require because it involves
Alzheimer's and Dementia they require a
co-participant or a witness with the
capability to witness all consents and
all pre screenings and it I think it's
required for every clinical trial to
have a full pre-screening to determine
whether or not a patient is eligible and
that's one of our biggest concerns is
that a prescreening may be done to
cursor not thoroughly enough or not
reasonably if you're trying to push
people through the system to get them
treatment quickly it may not be done
reasonably and it may cause more harm
than good
represent palazov thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my
question so uh I'm trying to uh
understand the situation that was
presented when uh doctors are afraid to
try anything and they would rather let
patients die than uh uh try a new
potentially life saving uh treatment uh
and allegedly it's because they afraid
of um malpractice attorneys and that
they will they will be uh fed uh
despite
uh prior agreement so could you comment
on it sure thank you for your question
um I think by making the amendment to
switching everything to terminal illness
from lifethreatening disease will be
part of that and the Federal Regulations
themselves already have an exception for
patients who are at imminent threat of
death the informed consent exception
doesn't apply for that there are
exemptions in that federal statute for
those precise situations when there
isn't time to get the full prescreening
or there isn't time to get the informed
consent because a patient is going to
die if they don't immediately if they
don't get the treatment so I think
that's already covered by federal
law other questions representative CLE
ring thank you Mr chair I'm trying to
word this in the proper way but why
would it matter if a or if a patient is
to that degree and they're about to die
you just outlin that federal law already
has a provision for it so why is it
important to under the law let's say to
do that if a patient has gone to that
extent just curious like if they're
about to let's say they're they're
imminent they've only got two weeks to
live why would you know why would the
provision or why would this not cover
that because that you're basically
stating that you know there's a tri the
trial period that you had like I think
your family member versus somebody that
is at the last last chance I mean you
said there's already provision in law
for that so why would this be different
I think that this bill would cover that
and it would still cover that if the
language was just changed to terminal
illness as it's currently defined in the
right to Tri
act
okay representative damus
thank you Mr chairman actually um I see
on line five on page one also it says uh
uh determine whether a person with a
life-threatening disease may be so if we
changed that language to terminal as
well would that be part of what we' need
to
do I would suggest that every reference
in the statute to life-threatening
disease should be changed to terminal
illness and that's already defined in
anyone
else saying no one else thank you thank
you
chairman also signed up to speak is
Aubrey
fredman uh Aubrey Mr chairman committee
members Aubrey Friedman I speak in
support of this bill
um it's weird
that it would I think everybody in this
room most people would want to help
somebody who wants to live
to have access to all
possible
uh drugs or whatever you know any
possible thing
and why would we uh why Would we not
make it easier for somebody to try
they're in the last there's nothing to
lose and they know it I and it it seems
this is a crazy world where there there
are things available and Doctors Medical
providers won't do that because they're
afraid of being sued that's crazy
so I I think this bill is great if
there's uh something in it that you
know let's change it a little bit
whatever but I mean this is crazy not to
go forward I mean does your body belong
to you or not the person I would seem to
me if they're in the a terminal they're
not going to be worried about suing now
maybe family members might be who knows
whatever you can't say but if they're
willing to sign that they're not going
to do it I mean what more does there
need to be so um and then the what was
it uh mean you either own your body or
not does it belong to you or the state
if the state is going to be so uh
protective of you that you're going it's
going to let you die doesn't make sense
also the remote signing the TAA uh tahel
uh
pre-screening uh that makes things
easier again we should be compassionate
and uh want to make things easier for
somebody who's obviously going to die or
is a terminal so why make it harder so
those are something and everybody does
remote things these days and so that's
not even a big deal um we should be
compassionate and I'm glad that there's
some teeth in this bill about protecting
the uh uh medical providers if they're
too afraid to help out then we need to
get rid of that uh so that people can
give them a chance to live so I I
totally support this bill that's it
thank you thank you any
questions seeing done thank you thank
you
no one else has signed up to testify
does anyone else wish to
testify seeing no one I am going to
close the public hearing on HB 701 FN
that concludes all of the public
hearings we had scheduled for
today uh perhaps a brief recess would be
in order and then we will go into
executive session on several bills thank
you uh 15 minutes is that too much okay
e
all
right I'd like to call the executive
session to order we've already exec one
of the five bills that I had mentioned
to a number of you but um we do have
four remaining I'd like to start off
with hr7 and representative Maser I
believe you have a
motion yes Mr chair thank you I would
like to move
hr7
itl for
y was H7 representative D seconds you
wish to speak to your motion yes um so
while we as we know while non-binding um
just a house resolution could be used to
justify future legisl or funding
decisions that a lot of taxpayers and
lawmakers uh do oppose so why and a
question I'm going to keep this sure is
why a house resolution on just this we
should be priori prioritizing policies
and Revol resolutions that address
adoption maternal care support for women
rather than specifically highlighting
abortion focusing so solely on abortion
in a resolution overlooks other crit
critical aspects such of such as support
for high-risk pregnancies preventive
care such as cancer screenings for women
and a lot more so that's why I'm voting
itl on this other
discussion representative Lucas thank
you Mr chair um I will be voting against
itl uh as long as there are potentially
deadly complications of pregnancy that
would take the life of the mother if the
pregnancy continued and as long as long
as there are crimes against women
including rape incest and sexual slavery
there will be abortion New Hampshire
should not victimize women for a second
time by failing to recognize the
importance of abortion in the provision
of comprehensive Healthcare thank you
thank you anyone else any other
discussion seeing none uh representative
Woods um thank you Mr chair um I I too
will be voting against it I I completely
agree with the previous speaker uh and
the the need for many dimensions of
Women's Health Care need to be
identified um and that perhaps is is a
time for another day uh but this
particular issue is is a specific issue
uh which in fact has raised uh a
significant social dialogue both
nationally U as Statewide and locally uh
and a lot of it very personal um and I
think it uh is a reflection of a
position which is uh um worthy of of
special attention and not to diminish
what a previous speaker mentioned that
other dimensions need to be addressed as
well and I I completely agree in that
regard uh but this is sufficiently
special uh that I think it deserves uh a
special place and a special comment
thank you thank you any other
discussion not I'll ask the clerk to
call the rooll motion is itl on
hrs7 rep merer yes rep mlan yes rep
damus yes rep kofalt yes rep poov yes
clerk votes yes rep Markel yes rep
McGrath yes rep kessing yes rep Weber no
rep McCay no rep
Woods uh
rep
no rep
TZ No rep lontine no partnet no rep
yes V is 10 to8 motion
Lucas
um I mean they won't make the calendar
today calendar today so by the weekend
would be wonderful by the end of the day
that'd be wonderful and represent paza
you're going to do that one we did this
morning
okay uh so moving on uh next up is
hr16 uh representative merer you have an
amendment yes yes thank you Mr chair I'd
like to introduce amendment number 2025
d07
57h um
OTP okay motion's been made by
representative Maser um on Amendment
0757 H ought to pass is second that I do
you want to speak to your
motion uh yes uh several of us on the
committee thought that the original bill
um didn't acknowledge um other Frontline
workers that were um that were
terminated um
during uh covid for declining the
covid-19
vaccination and they they deserve equal
acknowledgement um and and those that
lost their jobs due to the vaccine
mandates and encouraging policies that
recognize and reintegrate them back into
the healthc care
Workforce and affirms the importance of
medical choice and workplace protections
for all health professionals so we
thought that would Compass everyone that
was part of the Frontline workers in
during
covid representative
Weber thank you Mr chairman
one of the things I particularly
appreciated about the original bill as
originally drafted was that it
was very
all-encompassing and it was completely
non-political this amendment politicizes
the bill in a way that I think is
particularly
unfortunate and so I will be voting
against the amendment and and if the
amendment passes with great reluctance I
will be voting against the bill and I
would make it very clear that I am
unwavering in my support for Frontline
workers but I don't think that we need
to work
harder to enlarge the divides that we
are already grappling
with okay representative
palaza uh thank you uh Mr chair uh uh I
would agree that uh we need to support
Frontline vocus and
address address the shortage of
healthcare vocus but uh I see the bill
is originally written as very
political uh for example uh uh page
first lines five and six uh claim that
uh it was pandemic that uh slaten
economy and and and caed economic losses
when uh it is a political statement
because uh many of
us uh believe that it was actually a
government over reaction that destroyed
uh e economy uh the next uh line 7
to9 uh it uh uh lists uh only short of
vocus um uh as as main factor for lack
of services when many of us remember
that it was government who closed
hospitals to for delivering regular care
and regular
screening uh so so also even if uh we go
only from testimonies that were um
that we had in this committee uh there
was a testimony about very concerning
actions uh when anos was participating
in isolating
and uh family
members uh and
she understand that what she was doing
is wrong but it's totally excused
because it was at the order of DC but if
you look at page two line
five this bill is written it's actually
sanks and reaffirms CDC so this bill has
written is very political so this
amendment uh I think is needed to bring
at least some balance to it thank you
thank you anyone else representative
kofol thank you Mr chairman so I
actually don't see the original bill as
political and I don't see I I understand
why excuse me
um there there may be a a an initial
response to the amendment as being
political having said that I think it is
extraordinary I think many of us know
people who were fired when you know
because of a a medical personal medical
decision that they made and
um I I think the language in the in the
amendment is um acknowledges that many
people as as they were saying went from
Heroes to zeros all of a
sudden having said that I don't believe
that this should be the focus of the
bill I think it's important we
acknowledge it so if we pass the
amendment and are able to acknowledge
the um the Injustice that was done to
some people I think we can then turn our
attention to the over all positive
intention of the original House
resolution uh that's why I will be
supporting the amendment and um if it
passes I will support the house
resolution with a focus on the original
intent which is that we really ought to
uplift and acknowledge all of the people
who have um who who have and do have
responded and do respond um to crises
like the
pandemic representative
haret uh I share uh representative
Weber's uh disappointment I too was
looking forward to uh supporting the
initial bill and I'm really pretty
disappointed in the amendment I think we
brought a kind of political attention to
this that was we just don't need right
now it's unfortunate I think so I won't
McGrath so I'm one of the people that
the
amendment helps
to I guess
showcase I think that the bill is great
to support the Frontline
workers
um I wasn't fired for not getting the
vaccine but I was fired for standing up
for
children I am not I don't feel I'm being
recognized in the original bill
and although the resolution really
focuses on being fired for not getting
the
vaccine I feel that it does
integrate the two people the two kinds
of people that were on the front lines
um
and I would urge you to vote for the
amendment I feel like even though
specifically it doesn't represent me
that it kind of does and that's why I
would support this bill with the
else as a co-sponsor of the bill uh I
I'm prepared to vote for the amendment
but also vote for the ultimate
resolution whether it is amended or not
because I think the recognition of our
Frontline workers is is that that
important I always try to find the
middle ground whenever possible and and
um it's one of the reasons I'm
supporting the amendment because I I
know it addressed some concerns and
created others but anyway I'll be
supporting I'll be voting for both so
that being said if the clerk is ready
I'll anyone else
before saying no one uh I'll ask the
clerk to call the rooll motion is uh
ought to pass on
Amendment um one time 0757
H rep Maser yes rep mlan yes rep damus
rep kofalt yes rep poov yes clerk votes
yes Brett marel yes rep McGrath yes rep
King yes rep Weber no rep McKay no rep
Woods no rep elberger no rep TZ No rep
lontine no rep haret no rep Lucas no re
McDonald yes vote is 10 to8 motion
passes okay representative kofalt I move
out to pass with Amendment on house
resolution 16 um 16 and I will second
that any other discussion on
this
issue seeing none I'll give the clerk a
moment to catch up and sorry you ready
rep
merer yes rep
mlan yes rep
damus R kofalt yes R poov
yes clerk votes no rep marel yes rep
McGrath yes rep kessle ring yes rep
Weber no rep McKay no
rep
Woods rep elberger no rep tez no rep
lontine no rep hartnet no rep Lucas no
okay okay um representative um Cal
you'll be doing a report excuse me I'm
sorry the amendment failed so we're not
at a report yet didn't was no
recommendation would oh I'm sorry it it
went it went 9 to9 so it's without
report I'm sorry I beg your pardon I
will
actually um you're right we do have to
go through all of the Motions so I would
Amendment okay so represented of Weber
moves ought to pass
period okay
and um second was representative T
representative T seconds okay any
uh representative
mlan uh yeah thank you um Mr chair so um
I like the original uh amendment I I
thought it was affirmative um I thought
it was inclusive um I also did not have
any problems with the amendment because
contrary to see it as being political um
I felt it it was recognizing people and
and seeking to kind of pull people back
together so I did not not see it as um
divisive and so I I support it that
being said if if the motion is um ought
to pass I I will be supporting it
because I do think that the original uh
motion was an affirmative motion and I
do want to support
it anyone
else and as I previously stated I will
also support arop
pass all right anyone else going going
gone motion is ought to pass on hcr1
16 please call the well Mr Clark rep
Maser no rep mlan yes rep damus no rep
kofalt no rep poov no clerk votes no rep
marel no rep McGrath no rep kesslering
no rep Weber yes rep McKay yes rep Woods
yes rep taes yes rep lontine yes rep
eight and so so the majority motion
would be ought to pass and the other
motion would be
uh ought to pass as amended right
right we we did ought to pass as amended
and that tied so that that failed
because it was a tie and then the next
motion was ought to pass and that came
out 10 to8 so that passes V was 10 to
eight so is the question what what does
The Minority Report look like is that
the question yeah who's doing it I am
happy to write The Minority Report with
TPA that will The Minority
Report will reflect
otpa so it's there and if I may Mr
chairman that Amendment will just show
up in the calendar because he already
has the amendment in front of him so in
The Minority Report you write um the the
number in and the clerk will just make
sure that goes into the calendar for
people's consideration at that point and
uh in terms of the majority report who
made the the motion representative we
did I made the motion but it's your
bill so I guess I'm I guess I'm writing
you why don't you write it sorry who is
representative Weber is writing the
it's Unique
yes all right um any other thoughts on
on okay moving on to HB 117
motion okay and um is there a second
second representative brw
seconds um representative McGrath you
wish to speak to your
motion yes thank you um
so as a pharmacist um we interchange
drugs all all the time and I realize
that's what this is all about whether
this is actually interchangeable or not
so apparently they do do this in
saves a ton of
money um in the pharmacy it will save an
incredible amount of time which we have
very little of because they cut our
staff all the time
um and we we won't have to make calls
get prior
authorizations it will Empower us to
consult with the patient and make the
the decision with the
patient
um
and they're not exactly the same
medicine like a generic is but doctors
do this all the time they might try one
um cholesterol Med and it doesn't work
or it has side effects so they try a
different one so easily if there's a
problem or the patient has not getting
the results from the new medication it
gets switched to the other medication
just seems like um Common Sense Bill
thank you representative kof thank you
Mr chairman so uh many of you may recall
that this bill was first introduced in
the last session by The Honorable U Gary
Merchant and who is also the chair of
the prescription drug Advisory Board and
a champion of lowering um prescription
drug costs for patients um so I I I
actually have researched this fairly
extensively because uh you know I got
involved with with the bill last year
and um you know this distinction between
biosimilars and interchangeables is
certainly
confusing uh but um as representative
McGrath pointed out it's there there's
actually um you know in Europe they they
have dispensed with that so I think um
in the interest of saving patients money
um you know preserving patient safety um
I think this is a good bill and I plan
to vote for it thank you representative
Weber and in addition to what's already
been said I think the bill has decent
guard rails uh so that a provider who
doesn't want substitution can say so and
a patient who doesn't want substitution
can say so so uh I think they're
some protections there as well so I'll
be voting for it representative Woods uh
thank you I just Echo what
representative Weber said and add one
other thing I just a word of caution
just from the technical perspective
biosimilars are a very
diffuse definition right now uh are
fairly fairly concise but it's getting
more and more diffuse and I think we
have we're going to have to be attentive
to this issue I I will vote for it uh
but I just we going to have to be
attentive thank you anyone
else seeing no one else if the CLK is
ready I'll ask him to call all motion is
ought to pass on
hb17 rep merer yes rep mlan yes repus
yes re kofalt yes rep poov yes clerk
votes yes rep marel yes rep McGrath yes
rep kessing yes rep Weber yes rep McKay
yes rep Woods yes rep elberger yes rep
TZ yes rep lontine yes rep
hartnet rep Lucas yes rep McDonald
yes vot is 18 to zero motion passes
there any object consent any objection
okay see
none yeah representative McGrath you're
doing the report on this thank
you okay and then the final bill for
executive session today HB 732 FN and
representative kessle ring I believe you
have an amendment that you've
distributed yes I did Mr chair you wish
to move your Amendment and speak to it
and representative uh D I believe you
second you second would you like to
speak to your motion yes so there was a
concern um in the bill itself that there
was not a designated uh caregiver when
it comes to children that are in the
system or different things so worked
with OS to work out the specific State
designated caregiver which you can see
on line 11 uh shall be the department of
human health and services which is under
the RSA it backs it up and then further
down below it adds it in the other
that's now representative
Weber thank you and I appreciate the
effort but it doesn't fix the problem
because when a child is the subject of
an AB abuse neglect
petition and they have been removed from
their parents or sometimes even when
they are still with their
parents the parents retain their
parental rights until they are
terminated at the end of the proced
ceeding so there is a period of often a
year and sometimes more than that when
the parents are still the person with
the authority to consent and
DHHS um which in this case would be
DCF has no authority to consent I assume
without knowing that they could go to
the court and ask the court to give them
that but unless and until dcyf has been
designated the legal guardian of the
child which does happen but it happens
at the end uh and it happens under other
circumstances too but not to get too
technical about it unless DCF is the
guardian of the child designated by a
court they don't get to consent so we
still have children this doesn't fix the
problems there are children who are
still in limbo so to answer can I answer
your question so to answer that um OSS
said this specifically we needed to
include the RSA which we did that RSA
covers basically that child is still
under the that would have to be
regulated under that RSA for the parent
or Guardian the state does not have
guardianship yet but that RSA clarifies
when the state does take guardianship
that it can so that RSA supposedly by
adding it clarified it that was the
reasoning that we put it in there and we
added under that RSA so yes because of
the question that came up that's why
that RSA specific specifically listed in
there that it's under it that's what
I've been told for the legal side of it
so I was trying to clear up both the
language but also the intent and that is
supposedly under that RSA that is the
intent so just so you know
representative
haret I think we can all appreciate the
importance of making sure that kids and
their parents understand the risks of
psychotropic medications but as somebody
who's literally sat in onund hundreds of
prescribers with families and kids I've
always seen as a matter of standard
practice that the prescriber reviews
with the parents and the child what the
risks the benefits of the medications
are what the side effects are so it's
standard
practice um My worry is that we're
trying to sort of fix something that may
not necessarily be a problem I also have
concerns I appreciate representative L
montine always reminding us of
specifically uh just including Medicaid
patients if we're that this concerned
about uh prescribing uh practices for
kids why aren't we making it for all uh
miners additionally uh the requirement
to review the
FDA uh literature that accompanies these
medications I think representative Weber
pointed out um just how uh
impenetrable uh those documents are and
they won't really serve in addition to
inform uh parent or a child about what
the risks and benefits of the medicines
are so I will not be uh supporting uh
the bill representative Castle I'd like
to speak to that Mr chair specifically
to the I asked the same question to OSS
and I wanted to get to the bottom of it
because I did have concern that we
should expand it Beyond Medicaid um the
ru making was the question because under
certain Provisions that we put in
Medicaid as a whole they are made uh
let's say standards for the medical
professionals and they follow those so
the idea was that if we started here we
could always expand if there was an
issue but under Ru making more than
likely most medical professionals would
put that in place already themselves um
the secondary uh question was the FDA uh
disclaimer stuff so in the process I
asked for a little bit more detail on
that and said there is a simplified
version that the medical professionals
have just as you'd find on the bottle
which is a label so the information that
we were given by uh Mr or representative
cordelli was the full spec sheet from
the FDA it was not the simplified
version that the medical professionals
have or that the the what you call it
the um people that prescribed
medications would have anyways there's a
simplified version of that so just to go
with those question thank you
representative mlan
thank you Mr chair um first of all I I
want to thank representative Kel ring I
think I think he did excellent work
really in addressing some of my concerns
and and the followup that he did you
know in terms of understanding the scope
and to include Medicaid or or not to
include Medicaid he has certainly
answered that to to my satisfaction and
you know I certainly agree as well with
representative Harnet that probably
these discussions are happening um I
know that we have many doctors um on
this committee who are excellent doctors
I talk a lot with representative Palmer
who is not here but you know to get back
to something that you were talking about
this morning uh representative Woods
where we we're getting more and more
into the the corporatization of medicine
and I I see this myself quite a bit the
discussions that I'm having with my
physician and across the whole spectrum
of the healthc Care Now versus 20 years
ago what I find quite often is they're
looking for the signature and informed
consent and I understand this you know
you You' got to get people through you
got to get people through and it seems
to me oftentimes the the the end goal is
is getting that signature and I don't
think it's a bad thing it's you just
kind of get into a rhythm and that's
where you're going and so I'm not
speaking as to you know the morality of
people that's just what it is so I think
anything that we can do that modestly
and since this is already being done but
modestly proceduralized us putting on
the brakes um is not a bad thing and
this is modest because representative as
you pointed out it's already being done
so let's just kind of codify where we
are so that as this corporatization goes
along we've at least got the brakes
established I don't think this does any
harm and in the future I think will help
so I'll be supporting the
bill uh representative woods and then
representative MC
um thank you U I just need clarification
and those that deal with court with kids
um what happens in a situation in my
limited exposure as a hand surgeon saw
this on a few occasions where there was
a discrepancy between the position of
the husband and the wife in a
contentious
situation um and wouldn't uh acques to a
particular treatment until other things
have been settled where do we stand in
this
situation with you know um when there's
some kind of litigation between uh the
parents is that going to be left out in
this in this
bill Mr chairman yeah can I to address
that he he deals with family law yeah I
deal with family law on a regular basis
okay and if you're in a situ first
usually you will have either temporary
Ord is in place via a parenting plan uh
that will describe the rights and duties
of the parents and uh in those parenting
plans you can find online incidentally
they're they deal with medical treatment
they deal with decision making and a
bunch of other things in the event that
the parties were married or unmarried
either way if there was an emergency
action somebody can bring an action and
have it heard in front of a court uh so
if there is the standard there being
immediate irreparable harm to a child so
in other words if you had a a serious
problem that involved immediate
irreparable harm a parent can go to the
court and get exp parte orders so and
more likely than not if it just meets
even a minimal standard they be
granted would it would require some
additional intervention right it would
but uh you know but if you're asking if
there's conflict okay you're going to
probably either have a court courts are
Guided by the best interest of the child
standard which trumps virtually
everything so I does that answer your
question
sir sure represent McGrath that D your
hand
up so I definitely agree with rep
partnet that the doctors and prescribers
are
absolutely reading or giving informed
consent to the patients but I'll tell
you by the time they get to the pharmacy
they have noide idea what they heard so
having a piece of paper to go over and
which we also give out at the pharmacy
is good um and also you're right about
Medicaid becoming the standard of care I
know in the pharmacy if Medicaid
requires
something that's the way it is for every
single patient we
have representative lontine
uh yeah I'm going to oppose this bill
for one it is singling out Medicaid um I
wish that Medicaid was the standard of
care um or should I say Medicaid
reimbursements certainly aren't the
standard of care right like why are we
upholding this when their Medicaid
payments to Providers
are uh really not enough so here we're
adding additional bureaucracy and
paperwork for do
taking care of Medicaid patients it
seems like government
overreach and my I I was also thinking
earlier that every time I go pick up a
prescription the pharmacist always asks
me do I have any questions about it
we're already there's already a double
check on information provided so I feel
overreach uh representative Weber and
then represent presor
McGrath having had a chance to read the
statute I'm still left with a bunch of
questions but um in recognition of the
effort um I'm going to vote for the
amendment before I vote against the bill
for all the reasons that have already
been said uh the other thing to remember
is that this
is it's not even all of the Medicaid
kids it's Medicaid to school
programs and it sounds to me or it
sounded to me during the testimony and I
don't want to ascribe motive to people
because I am sure that it could be wrong
um I know that people are concerned
because I read it all the time that
their parents are somehow being treated
at the schools without the parents not
under not being notified and that is
completely unacceptable but what we
heard with respect to these procedures
is the school set at with the parents
involved at the five 504 the IEP and it
is the health care provider with the
parents already giving informed consent
so I don't think it's necessary and I
don't think that having extra Hoops for
one class of people is a good idea so I
will vote for the amendment but against
the um against the final product
representative
MRA I just wanted to respond to uh rep
lontine if your Pharmacy is asking if
you have any questions I'll
guarantee 100% of the people will say
no ideally they should be coming to you
and asking open-ended questions to make
sure you understand what you're getting
and that sort of thing but just to say
do you have any questions is is not what
they should be
doing representative Weber and I had one
more thing which was that if what is
presented to the parent is the 17-page
document that we were given which was
not written in any kind of readable
language um I would be very distressed
because it isn't very helpful um and
I'm not in the 100% of people who don't
ask their pharmacist questions because
mine's wonderful and I ask questions all
the time representative kessle ring
thank you Mr chair I I want to give you
a frame of reference why I felt so
strongly about this because it's it's
kind of important to say I had been
given a medication and I asked my
physicians's assistant who had
prescribed it there that day and ask
questions she couldn't provide me the
questions I needed she said the
pharmacist will be able to help you
I went to the pharmacy because she was
the end of the day trying to get me out
it seemed like I went to the pharmacy
and the pharmacist couldn't have could
give me the questions I needed so I took
the medication didn't have any questions
and then I tore my killes tendon two
weeks later and they said that was a
side effect so for me it was very
personal in this fact that we need to
hear like what those side effects are so
I just wanted to state
that anyone
uh thank you I I think there's been a
lot of really good points made um
already for why this is problematic I
will add that as someone who spent a lot
of time trying to figure out how do you
help people understand meaning patience
or people in communities understand
information I agree with representative
Weber the handout is completely
useless um and most Americans that's
everyone overall need things written
between 6th and e8th grade reading level
so if we were to approve a an
understandable handout it would be
helpful to see that before we just say
yes we're going to do the FDA form and
then if we really just wanted to make
sure there was information we could say
that when one of these medications is
dispensed at the pharmacy that they
can't opt out because right now I think
what we do is what was mentioned
everyone signs I decline to speak to the
pharmacist because we're all in a hurry
and we sign and we go on our way and we
don't take advantage of the opportunity
provided by the law previously created I
don't know I don't remember when that
pharmacists must offer counseling
because that wasn't always that way so
there's other ways to um achieve the
objective uh and um you know both having
um known a lot of providers and also
having you know mother of a child who
needs medicine I I'm very familiar with
the amount of rigor that goes into the
prescribing the counseling the ongoing
monitoring um the you know making sure
everything's okay and so I don't think
that a punitive there needs to be
signatures and people are at risk I
don't think that's constructive for
anybody and it just creates a lot of um
bureaucracy and potential challenges
that really aren't going to improve
things overall okay were you ready to
vote no add one thing real quick if I
can Mr chair so just I I guess the
question would be to ask the pharmacist
um what the simplified version is that
they have because they have the
simplified version that I was told is
the the label version of it so it would
be a lot
smaller yeah we were we were provided
with that so yes there was the big one
but there were also some the yeah the
other ones as well so we that was in
there representative ml yeah so when
when during the the testimony um that
they he they had the 17-page FDA a hand
but it's at the very back that part is
the medication guide so that so it's not
the whole thing it's just that little
chunk at the back yes represent of Tes
yeah as someone who has done a fair
amount of um content knowledge about
health literacy as a concept most 40% of
Americans overall are are low health
literacy that means they cannot
understand basic instructions so um I
think it's really regrettable that what
happened did you read your package
insert because there's one in the
medicine there's the handout that comes
with the receipt that the farm like they
give you now three or four pages
whenever you pick up any medicine and so
I think that this is not the way to
solve the problem I agree that there the
the system doesn't work ideally all the
time and I think there's ways to make
improvements I just don't think that
this particular Improvement will achieve
what is um being purported as what is
the desire
um outcome and so um you know there's
there's ways to make information more
understandable there's ways to um oh
again back to the I'm sorry lost my
train of thought but I I I like the idea
of making it mandatory that the
counseling be received at the
pharmacists in addition to the handout
that's getting slipped into the
bag represent cast and just to answer
your question I did read it but there
was only four side effects out of the 47
or 50 that were actually listed so it's
just one of the further one down just
just for the
record all right are we all set I think
we are all right the motion before us is
yes rep King yes rep Weber yes rep McKay
Woods yes this is the amendment the
amendment rep elberger yes RIP tez yes
RIP lontine yes RIP
hartnet rep Lucas yes and R McDonald yes
vote is 17 to1 motion passes
you want to change your vote yeah I'm
sorry I tried to interrupt myself there
sorry I oh okay so the vote is 18 to Z
18 Z okay representative Kling do you
have another
motion ought to pass is
amended uh representative kessle ring
moves ought to pass as amended on HB 732
FN representative Drew do you have a
second second representative due seconds
any other
discussion seeing none uh when the clerk
732 rep Maser yes rep mlan yes rep damus
rep kofalt
yes rep poov yes clerk votes yes rep
marel yes rep McGrath yes rep kessing
yes rep
Weber no rep McKay no rep Woods no rep
elberger no rep Taz no rep lontine no
rep
hartnet rep Lucas no rep McDonald yes
vote is 10 to8 motion
passes
okay um okay repr cast you will write
the majority report on that and I assume
there'll be a Minority Report by someone
haret what's that motion going to be
pass otpa
yeah no the the minority minority it
itl I guess there's no itla I don't know
what I'm thinking okay Lisa so again
thank you everyone it's been a long day
but thank you all uh that's all we had
scheduled so um unless somebody has a
question or anything pleas stand